volevo buttare fortissimo in partenza se
non sono i 50 anni perché effettivamente
questo canale ha dei valori che non
avrei distrutto questo tube bella a
tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video io sono felice volo che fai
video su youtube da sacco di tempo anche
grazie all'idea che un giorno ebbe un
mio amico chiamato nitide che oggi ecco
la dea ragazza buongiorno a tutti allora
c'è anche il buon leo che salve
effettuata ragazzi oggi è un gran giorno
e ce ne sono stati tanti nel mondo prima
voi quando è risorto gesù uscì classi
sunto di for guys quindi quindi
finalmente possiamo essere faccia
ragazzi ciao a tutti state commettendo
possiamo essere luoghi felici contenti
di provare questa nuova espansione
espansione season
la prima volta che io mi attaccò un
gioco che ha deciso quindi non è che
quindi è una moderazione un a mo di opa
stagione dalla mia come serie tv per
fermare esatto ci sono d 13 di volgari
quindi ciao ragazzi grazie a tutti
grazie di grosso giulio perabo nazione
grazie a joel è eterno per la donation
partiamo subito con for guys jonas
allora torniamo un attimo un po
commentato la faccenda qua allora
abbiamo scaricato la patch la fece
subito su computer pesa un quinto sulla
ripresa si predica sulla play qua però
600 metri
va bene giannina proprio videogioco
corazze dei liberatori solo alberto del
rio preto nations tex quel convinta
giacomo caro gianfy grazie alla non
siamo né ragazzi dovrete sopportarci
cela c'è la super ciatto cari fianco del
pero domandarci messaggio 10 qualcosa
sono il super speaker
oppure potete fare l'abbonamento o
abbonati one qua sotto col tasto
abbonati per sopportare cercarsi mille
intanto per il supporto nell eleggiamo
tutte orchidea al maschile non si può
dire
ragazzi non iniziare a fare una bella
partita perché è importante fare quello
anche perché faccia vedere che tutte le
ski che abbiamo maturato su polgai sarà
qualcosa tanto a bassette tech insomma
spoleto nation caro e partiamo subito
con la cola live di folk ice season
g.ve vediamo subito che è cambiata la
schermata iniziale allora perfetto
abbiamo ripartito da zero quindi livello
1 season progress orazio scarafone
grazie mille caro gag gex grazie mille
ed elaborazione caro vediamo
innanzitutto se hanno messo le nuove
skin come mi interessava porca vacca
duchessa te la puoi prendere con 11.000
punti che non sono niente perché io ho
finito tante di quelle volte
sono tante di quelle volte prima che per
me questi sono soldi spicci prendiamoci
la skin duchessa completa che vidi che
dite ragazzi la nomina così perché uno
può scappare subito li cuti
se io non ho bisogno di sciopero che non
miliardo e mezzo mi dico precoci subito
la nuova skin e vediamo un po come
allora le indosso direttamente ok pagato
lo scatto perfetto pensano un figlio se
posso permettermi e poi o la chaine mail
che praticamente sarebbe l'armatura dei
dei soldati perfetto che non so se
prendervela o meno ma
per adesso dire di no e poi c'è la pesca
come come a ci sono anche con sé come
tipo col saint come si chiamano il call
of duty polica mettono col saint quelli
che di quelli quando vicini qualcuno che
compare kolles calde le signe in
italiano è praticamente che servono per
personalizzare il tuo nome quando
abbassi qualcuno paramassi nessuno ma
che for guys però vabbè nickname gente
come te io voglio sbloccarmi la skin da
kebab atac e baba che fa maro la cucina
e bar
grazie mission degli sci valdivilla
ragazzi poi scegliere giorno adesso vedo
una in è sciocco in sceglie di scegliere
bene un attimo perché voglio un attimo
perché non si vedeva mai la skin del mio
personaggio migliore è giusto che la ri
modifichi addio ma che costruì ai
brother scusa è che cos'è la scolte
scolastica
mettiamo questo no non vi piace veniamo
così ben noto non è male questo mettiamo
questo non è male è un parolone sono
veramente un figo e tu non ti di x men
mai più mai ma non ti permettere di
parlare male la mia skin mai più perché
allora un attimo che
a secco solo la faccia che secondo me è
la tengo bianca papanews vale ragazzi
allora sono una duchessa portatemi
rispetto e poi tutti fate schifo
adesso invito l'ambiente abbiamo
invitato stesso spaccio non a caso
evitato stefan che tu non sei on line
io ma come sei mi ha messo ho invitato
nando io va bene neanche tanto step per
sbaglio ok perché c'era già stato stessi
per sbaglio e allora via verso la di
oggi centrato il pilota è laddove si
dovesse avere armi forse no lega entra
nora che aveva spesso facciamo entrare
si aspettano anche inaspettati offerti
fermi fermi fa in altri allora un attimo
che lo facciamo entrare servito io ho
inviato per sbaglio e non peggio che in
quattro e rai 4 in 3 mansioni è una
aspetta che lo chiamo lo chiamo qui non
4 al 4 si sa per ora è nuova è perché
non si poteva aspettare massimo in tre
anni prima
veniamo pure prima si poteva 4t s
aspetta di idoneo ds non lo so c'è
scritto nel gruppo stava fa consenta
regala spettati sì sì l'ho ce l'ho ce
l'ha il ps salvatore grazie mille per la
genesi un brodo per andare di nuovo
aspetto domando io mandavano perché ci
stavano 8 milioni stato inattiva ragazzi
che ci organizziamo per giocare insieme
così eccolo qua ho trovato troppo o
trovava live dove giochiamo con con gli
iscritti raga solo una volta al mese
giusto lati la live cosa però giochiamo
con gli iscritti una volta al mese una
volta mente ragazzi grazie mille per le
donazioni al sito fa quando fai la rete
un contro contro controllare per questo
ha detto questa cosa che lei grazie
intanto salvatore vediamo se riusciamo a
far entrare anche step che facciamo una
bella season
una partenza io non vedo l'ora di
prendermi un ancora infatti ci lavora in
faccio certo ancora paura a muro oggi al
tour va bene se la vinci cosa fare i
compiti di non vincerla ma scherzi
allora vediamo se mi ha scritto qualcosa
mi sento fuori luogo comunque ve siete
tutti tirati tutti belli io sono uno
talk va bene magari non ci sono più le
angurie chi lo sa speriamo sisters come
state comunque la cassoli cercando di
capire perché step sta cercando sta
registrando il video di domani quindi
hanno capito se vuole parlare o non lo
sta dicendo in questo momento se appena
miglia all'ok parto è stato
immediatamente ragazzi abbiamo milano ok
ok perfetto va il padre di let's go
tutto bene era ok va bene ma mi dicono
se vi diamo tutti il 40
prima si vedeva solo per avervi solo te
stesso cadere dai 26 a cinque persone
stanno facendo qualcosa invece no
dovremo rifare il gruppo perfetto anche
lasciato tutto meglio parlare come
annuncia il gracchio come onde ma l'ho
appena detto valeva appena che io devo
imparare a stare zitto allora no perché
io ho visto che tra l'altro c'è shaun
selector che non ho capito che cacchio è
scusatemi etico cambi modalità ma non ho
capito quello capito come comunque si
può giocare in quattro per non si vada
gioca in quattro sì sì sì voglio prima
lo giuro secondo me non me lo ricordo ma
l'hai vista oggi le ho viste mesi fa
secondo me non si poteva giocare in
quattro per lui e cosi rivals e l'hanno
fatto in quattro e allora sono babbo io
non lo sapevo non ero convinto che si
potesse giocare in tre anni ma se non so
perché si poteva giocare di così non
sapevano cosa allora io ero con chi mi
ha convinto proprio convintissimo
francipane ragalato nazione brother
grazie mille franchi da semi le gare
anche francesco classe via platone shaun
caro si parte facciamo questa che sia
una bella season e divertiamoci ma
soprattutto cosa più importante vinciamo
mai allora è importante vincere
cominciamo le sei partite siamo bisogna
spaccare il game siete usciti tutti
essi ci ha fatto scelte io basta ci sono
testi della valle arriva divario voglio
giocare si può giocare a questo gioco
senza uscire tra uscire con gli amici
soprattutto gli amici niente ma deve
stare perché lui è contento ma sono così
vedere ma le mappe nuove quali cacchio
sono aspettavamo entro eccoci qua
saltiamo by ke skifo 2 ogni volta fa
terreni e meno allevato zulu anche a me
va rilevato che stanno avendo un po di
problemi serve perché saranno 8 milioni
di persone a giocare però porca vacca
ok niente lo spagnolo cambiasse invece
niente è uscito di nuovo uscito male non
esce ragazzi io ero entrato il peso
riuscito anch'io
anche se ti fai tu il gruppo dei va bene
che palle non hanno tolta si sono
infatti non hanno colto si sa ora grazie
a quanto pare non hanno tolto si sa sono
uscito perfetto mi è uscito da solo tra
l'altro va bene va in vita v.to che non
ho invitato deve invitare steps però poi
a me non è arrivato niente aspetto a
posto allora di julian join the park
leisure invitami dai che ti dice io
chiaramente passo diventerà timori fi
privandoli fallo invitato di nuovo dice
sordi sony dice falla pure scusatemi
ragala trasmesso il video io
ho fatto il primo arrivato gioca tori
utenti gente parti si parla bene allora
io lo riavvia un attimo perché secondo
me sta avendo dei problemi esiste tali
questo gioco non indifferenti ma cui la
musica sempre alla lavoriamo sorridente
giorni le parti a giocare con gli amici
scusatemi sarà un po ho detto sempre di
invitarci lui sta invitando step vediamo
ma perché uk join the cazzo di parti in
gioco
madonna ma lo faccio in un gioco
multiplayer in grado di gruppo alle
persone io l'ho riavviato perché la
musica che mi sembrava strano
adesso con molta calma magari abbiamo
più ragazzina che cacchio hanno fatto ma
tutto a posto
a parte smin chiarlo gioco cosa hanno
fatto hanno aggiunto le mappe nuove
spero di sì quasi quanto tempo per entra
in una partita di faul guys invitato di
nuovo oggi niente martina non si può
fare niente amici però o i server sono
imploda avevo capito che ci sarà un
miliardo di gente che gioca la madonna
dai gioco dell'anno ha fatto il boom di
play e non sapete fan server che
dovrebbe essere 8 milioni di server prof
le cave rigato l'invito è solo che io ci
metto un po aspetto ecco vi invito
comunque giovanna così fratelli
ok allora dentro to stop the ok aspetta
invitatemi sito brocca lo aspetta il
loro abito io step la mia mente era
impallato da musica e quello mobile
vai vai avanti
questa è la volta buona me lo sento
italiano e che ne posso più giulia
grazie mille
platone sistema falco grazie anche a te
c'era quindi cui avete lei quanto è dura
tendenzialmente fino alle 8 poi vediamo
se aumentare un pochettino se stesso
parere di base fino alle 8 per perché
sono arrivato un po tardi ragazzi
scusate mi stavano facendo dei lavori
abbastanza importanti di video che
vedrete chiamando la balena switchato
adesso ok gigi è va bene ragazzo tenevo
webcam e ragazzi perché tanto per
partire ci mette non so quanto cuore ma
pure dove 55 su 69 lontano dai player
quindi immagino che debba accontentarmi
ma perché si vede che solo lost e li
vede entra solo lost e gli altri half
organico dvd player paga mela caricata
la qualità niente uscito dai che il kaki
devo dire provò a fare una roba un
attimo esce un attimo dal gruppo nichi
per me è affatto piaciuto che avrei
giocato solo tu se esci un attimo dal
gruppo ne esce un secondo facciamo suo
test 6 situ rimaniamo noi treno e mi
devi dare il tempo però perché cominci
ad accendere la partita tutto quanto
possiamo scartare in tre perché secondo
me hanno messo prevenire probabile
nessuno se funzionali ok
allora abbandono il gruppo vai vai fate
reding non mi fanno anche ready e faide
di cazzo non lo fa sapere dato che ero
io lo stesso divino corre di meno si sa
se l'ordine lei non mi pare di non mi
farei di me ne lascio schiacciare
letta proprio accordo ok proprio uscire
ma ti avevo la commissione anche dal
gruppo a no si può succede al gruppo
ok vi invito io a me mese è rimpallato e
di senza musica strano limpidamente ma
fa niente
una musa di piazza f ok però vedere se
parti in 3 join medici se anche a me
dice mi fa vedere musica incazzata cioè
il senso di parte di tre secondi si vede
che è in virt profondità io aspetto che
io non posso essere succube
dell'incapacità della gente di saper
fare un videogioco ma posso fare una
partita multiplayer allora for guys lì è
fermo for guys rientra in for guys dico
a tutti quanti vi rientra rientrate
tutti riavviate tutti folk ice riavviate
tutti fall guys
che palle live iniziata da 15 minuti
ancora abbia fatto la partita
in quindici tre vittorie per poi
flashback del match making di 70 minuti
di escape from kharkov basta cosa sai
porci
secondo the rocket league verrà nominato
come forte no ragazzi costano discorso
madonna non è che se è un
se la replica preso forse rocket league
non è che lo rovina secondo me no possa
votare un plus sono più sono molto
convinto di questo
allora nando nichi box step vediamo
arrivo i suoi tempi tecnici del circolo
tempi tecnici del pci ha capito chi sono
io la g vedo anche sterzo e stef allora
la al mio tre
per in b da me facciamo ora è di tutti
insieme non si sa non cambia niente ma
proviamo al mio tre treni tanto non ci
sente il live però quando dico uno
sempre schiacciare esso schiaccia adesso
schiacciate testate e noi spetta 30
secondi a portiamo a casa schiacciato
voce moderata da andate a cagare pietro
adesso la comodità avevano nei fumetti i
vostri gatti tanto non cambia niente
famosa sincere ed i file ai bimbi dai
sono curioso della del delle mappe nuove
sono me le fanno provare però sa quanto
sei vedo un ibra
giocare al gioco bene ma conosciamo
queste ragioni abbiamo già fatto la voce
della stagione 2 questa seconda stagione
ragazzi entrare guardi che la mappa che
già c'era però con difficoltà questo
abiti cambiato il colore della linea
della liga 3 gb
questi sì ma una cosa è cambiato
leggermente più chiaro invece che il
rosa e tipo rosa chiaro non ho capito
niente mi metto insieme però mai le
controllate fatti stava cercare io ma
che cazzo dici mi stavo scervellando sai
a capire
va bene ero anche bravo in trova le
differenze insieme infatti lascia
perdere come sono fatto colpire lega
perché non so mai se mi va domanda più
veloce è un'opera importante andare va
bene allora e mappe nuove saranno tra le
ultime immagini credo l'abbiano messa in
rotation spero avesse rotation speriamo
lega perché almeno ci pensi poi facciamo
perchè lo vuole prima mag sono quelli
sono quasi primo però non passa dal
centro perché a me con la roma non
funziona io sono quasi ultime invece
faccio il lisi skip lisi vision guai
però dai è passato dal centro che ci
provano incredibile secondo lega da due
volato curato e mick ma cosa hai fatto
come ha fatto arrivato terzo grazie a
dio
peccato perché è volato un pizzaiolo
hanno cambiato made in basso a sinistra
che ci sono i costi quando guardi la gsv
codificate lo vedete detto bene serve sì
raga non esco sede un film significa
tema applicato anche ho paura di non
riuscire a riparare la fai bene per sé
lo bello che ci siamo tutti tranne di
dio si sono mai arrivate non faccia a
faccia ma è l'ultimo proprio il real a
te culo trentasettesimo
ma vieni l'oro e occhio la donna ma
stesso incerto
non so se no non c'è vedo un pirata non
vedo un pirata neanche io però no dai
spero che ci sia non lo vedono tanti ma
magari è cambiato skinn e fucka lasciato
port cavata e niente finiamo questa più
che altro step farne una tu perché sennò
via non finiamo più vedo che ci sono
delle mappe come mentre mentre vedi che
tra vedere vero se si spuntano nella tu
style perché se noi non ce la facciamo
proprio a uscisse ci mettiamo due ore a
partire se non farne una farne una poi
massimo ti aspettiamo per quella dopo
capito se la starti adesso tanto
dovremmo finire
dovremmo finire uguali va bene allora
l'oro in rage chiaro lancio tutto per
aria
va bene che è giusto e anche joe è anche
giustissimo allora l'obiettivo di oggi è
vincere le mappe nuove ragazzi speriamo
di vedere l'avranno sicuramente messi e
rotation spero siano questa una prima è
fatta da ho visto vista sono più grande
va bene ma tanto sono solo io e la
duchessa richiama tutto a posto
cioè era l'unica leggendaria che ti
potevi comprare con i kudos che non ce
ne erano finora di leggendarie che tipo
di comprare con i ponti normali e
nessuno se l'è presa nessuno ci abbiamo
prendo dopo da quanto quanto costa
12.000 la parte noi quando chiude 22k
tutto ma anche anch'io ma infatti anche
anche tu anche anche io ma infatti
strano che nessuno ce l'abbia qua perché
immaginavo tutti con questo invece no io
l'ho messa perché se no avevo sempre a
stessa king ma io aspetto che facciano
le skin con le serie da cavaliere tutte
quelle lì che fanno che fanno poi più
avanti nel season stato c'è un sacco di
coronel e posso spendere prof
vediamo di prendere un altro paio di
corone proprio oggi
speriamo
sai che quello stava accadendo cade al
ahmar cadendo stava accadendo non volete
se ci sono mele gravare che sarebbe
la silvia ma un gas su folk ice
sarebbe bellissimo trovi gli impostori
mezzo alla gente ma anche altre ragazzi
dai caveau l'altro non sai chi è la vita
proprio nuove anche oltre che le mappe
perché me le modalità sono semiti paul
tipo che ne sarà delle cose magari la
farina un'altra mappa però è sempre
quella io spero che le cose la pianta
volte però va beh ne manca uno accade
rega non mi spingere non mi grabar e non
fare nulla gioca al tuo gioco come io
gioco il mio per gli impostori sono
feriti gravi non è sempre immaginata
skinny macinnes wood sul for guys bayern
da ragazzi sta un concept del majin bu
ci sta un concept ib ma ci ho visto
anch'io è bellissima la mia ragazza mi
lasciato vai tranquillo car gioca fall
guys è vero che un botto più filo del
gioco su pc è lo vedi lo vedi la
differenza lazio la vedi di base si la
gente se tu non ho visto che master ai
cani ed i colori più accesi non sono
stupido seppur io non sono più accesi
colori ragazzi ha finalmente tragica
spesi bene allora il rosso il rosso per
ora faccio lo skipper ragazzi ma solo
perché sono primo è teoricamente non
vorrei avere problemi ma l'ho detto e ci
prova pure io mamma mi hanno fatto il
bravo dei cori correte non non lasciate
è molto più saturato ma scusate e si è
incredibile veramente naturalissimo a
niente perché devi cadere non ti reggi
sulle tue gambe molli
ok ora guarda che mi spingono a hanno
cambiato il colore dei dei cosi qua sono
tutti i veicoli diverso sarà il claim
mantenuta ragazzi perché è la miglior
mappa che che esista un nome c'è a
livello proprio di fattura
fattura non nel senso alla milanese
fatto nel senso di come è fatto comunque
è fatta meno cioè a livello di colore
stampa tedesca si sta roba qua livello
migliore
ho fatto lo script del martello che un
bijoux arrivò primo la j
mamma mia che è campione come sto
arrivando
vi faccio vedere le mondiale le volte
nuova che odia in questa del robot che è
molto carina igotgame airtech insomma
scuole donation caro grazie mille madama
infatti la saturazione era aumentata di
bestia c'è madonna incredibile è che ora
grazie mille non sia stata votata prima
ma che sanno tutto grazie mille per il
supporto ragazzi
niente adesso vediamo di seguire non
hanno ancora messo il fatto che questo
caso accaduto baffa cuore quello dei
tanto né fare quello casca qualcuno io
dai ci prova a vedere se riesco serie
scava può costarti è così anzi l'ho
visto solo gli iniziali già garino licia
che arriva dice che arriva no ma se era
questo che mi arrivavano volario bollo
aveva gente lo sa ma santoro che
categorie modo da solo ma devi essere
proprio risoluto e ancora poche file può
prenderlo e fare con cattiveria rally
l'alcol è poi passata al cuore azzurro
sembra che sia la ricerca di abbraccio
nessuno nessun abbraccio free hugs alla
fine credo solo io so di chi latino è
una lingua ed è bene anche giusta xvi
potrebbe essere football non lo so
perché non so se ci sono nuove mappe da
due team hostesses con e del server
daniela vecchio inneggiamo cara grazie
mille polmoni infatti incredibile però
così da mantenere e saprà tutte nuove
da allora vediamo se c'è un finale nuovo
effettivamente
perché per ora però c'è la modifica
delle porte che c'è il portiere
quindi occhio del pendolo sì buttatevi
subito occhio sempre qualcuno importa
cio chiama roque click e ragazzi tutti e
tre quindi no veleni che è morto
giochiamo rocket iii linked e leo pd sai
come muoverti hanno cambiato la musica
inutile le mie inizio che ti sei minuti
segna lo stesso sembra crazy frog questa
canzone davvero bravi se non si sa se
sia stato scervellando a capire cosa mi
ricordasse ragazzi temi che estetico vi
prego che non si può soprattutto io vi
supplico central iverson gente che e
gente
bravi tutti in difesa meno qualcuno ad
attaccare che cacchio ok l'ho spinta
qualcuno dietro ecco la cura c'è
qualcuno bravo sia chiesi se c'è nessuno
molla qua e la partita difficile vai
spingete si gente spingendo il pin
gestionali del primo angolo di avere
spingete spingete spingete fi detto
prima tanto sarà entrando non è entrata
perché il bello e la parata sea e se
erano il vendola entrare volte se fosse
per me ne distaccava anche il pendolo si
staccava tutto il pendolo sarà nostra
quello poteva parlare la ragazza mi
invita a barack insidiosa a fare gol
anche con la banana è certo devi farlo
in casa non casinò quanto fate gol
ragazzi fanno e la ballerina ragazzi non
mi fate pia infarti e spingete st
bharara regala dall'altra parte questa
nostra porta santo iddio erano tutti i
nostri che hanno spinta dentro c'era
veramente di trogloditi sono l'unico
dietro no a cavallo alato io guarda me
li sono saltati tutti qualcuno che tira
nessuno anzi la palla va bene tutti i
romeni campo perfetto ma il neo papà la
sua dopo un attacco
e devo spingerla perfetto qualcuno che
tiri sono entrava la banana non avevamo
vinto ma questo l'ho saputo a lui ma sei
stupido ma la cosa non è entrato
scusatemi ma non lo so ma non devono
dietro il lavo raga quella palla limita
mi fa veramente paura che dovrei fare io
non posso fare tutto io regala porca
vacca vi prego big and jean keyless go
grafica 1 celo celo celo celo celo
niente giorno difesa di casa difesa di
massima sì questa è buona di questo in
contropiede incredibile questo è un
contropiede la cina che ha d'altra parte
ci sarà qualcuno sì sì sì sì di mamma
mia ora insistono ma il gol così gente
bravissima sento queste cose grandi
grandi grandi bene ben due ore se non
entrava la banana era una frase che
comunque era un po ambigua prova
d'attore main gran finale vediamo
chissà se ci hanno fatto no glielo ha
fatto una sola
voglio vedere una nuova finale dai
ragazzi una nuova finale
ecco la bella sala belli siano mai fatto
la chissà come sembra una montagna
sembra una montagna c'è la corona alla
fine ragazzi io credo non ne sono sicuro
che bisogna arrivare primi alla corona
potrebbe prenderlo a toccare i brand a
riprendere credo tocchi secondo mercati
e poi non lo so e non ho mai fatta però
teoricamente dovrebbero le riescono dove
le valli cascano le miscele pare che
cascano recap l'occhio noi io però a
passare quella destra che non funziona
no ma ragazzi ma è bellissimo saranno
dell'ajax unici questi ragazzi ho la
palla sul nardon a bala suonando
poverello fa niente fa niente
il ninja ai annuncia il via ai visto che
l'inter non era afflitto dal martello
che strana stavolta è arriva la gente
sbagliato ma che sono venute la prima
volta che lo fa c'era prima volta che la
facevo quindi non potevo saperlo
vabbè peccato peccato carlo il problema
mi piaceva questa mappa la bellissima
bella della sapa nuova mi piace un sacco
era una bella mappa ragazzi parte bene
questa sì lo vediamo se hanno messo
delle mappe nuove
nel frattempo e non so se ce li tagliamo
io venni invitato non so se accetta
tanto fa ace dall'orbita 3 2 1 let's go
se facevi il 3 2 1 tubini kira perfetto
perché rei di subito ma perché io l'ho
messo prima avevo già messo prima ero
tranquillo e mai non vedo il numero però
era gara ma io lo vedete adesso no che
sì si cibano buon'ora moro sveleranno
abbiamo cambiato strano secondo me di
nico di una bella cosa ma fallì mi
piaceva story di farla story di farla
come si chiamava fallo palla balla o in
montagna
allorché shania quale montane vabbè dai
va bene va beh però bello bello mi è
piaciuto bellissimo di adesso benvenuti
tutti quanti diventerà la mia preferita
quella se si è fatta benissimo mi sembra
un sacco meritocratica perché in base a
come sali
secondo me e quindi mi sembrava molto
bella io direi che secondo me si può di
fare si può rifare
veronica grazie mille per la comece non
è capitato prima questa invece era
quell'ampia delle lancette no no credo
credo visto le lancette prima cosa fa
era quella nuova dell'ancella si sarebbe
da chiesa quando completare le eliche
quella della fine di evitare dell'elica
fichissimo perché parto primo proviamo
priano dai vediamo un po come acqua
ragazzi mi sa che se vi fate ogni tanto
anche spingere la lancetta e possibile
che vi fate andare perché andate più
veloce non lo so è poi come hai fatto
delle targhe diplomi a vedere prima
vedere o ha funzionato una gamba
cacchio non avendolo ai fatti ha
funzionato come tecnica incredibile l'ho
scoperta subito senza senza preparazione
né niente ho visto c'è una volta più che
se adesso per ora però pensiamo a questa
questa partita assieme anche quando fa
il j fashion scoppia la moda da sempre
di più
perfetto mi fanno ridere quelli che si
buttano ancora nella nella corsia
centrale con centrale è impossibile è
impossibile passo sempre esatto come
faccio passi semplice
ecco come ho parlato poi l'ho fatta una
volta sta ma bambini non lo so però è di
base non sono passato con la volta li
ama infatti ciao zio sono un sacco di
player perché la rai tre
mamma mia ok ci sono io stai stefan
diamo le coop davo brother bella è che
ti fa vedere in basso a sinistra rischio
rischio rischio rischio rischio e aver
rischio non arrivi 28 che non ho visto
perché molto soft ma speriamo che pensa
questa è l'epoca cosa fosse ma si ok ce
l'ho fatta lei è così bella come stiamo
bene ce ovvero all'attesa ciao bello
bello le mappe nuove per adesso viene
passare un sacco mi piaceva quella
finale dove visse dovete di scalare la
montagna se lei
vediamo adesso cosa ci fa vedere nuove
quelle bellissime giochino che si fanno
se ne caro le foto hanno aggiunto le
vede in fuochi cosa fai la testa della
sanità le foto si può non love perché ai
ragazzi una dove girano le piattaforme
rimane solo vista primaria camera meglio
perché allora praticamente ci sono
piattaforme che girano e che io nei
buchi in mezzo se cadi e vie se
eliminato quindi devi stare interne rai
tra una piattaforma all'altra perché
secondo me è un pendolo sono sempre là
della strategia secondo me è curata ma
secondo me potrebbe l'abbiamo fatta
prima l'aveva fatta prima
almeno una volta avete provato aveva ben
donde il messaggio a parte gli scherzi
ma scusate ma poi due giocati se c'è
quindi adesso vi invitiamo anche fare ma
si possono caricare testiamo da un pc
con un joystick e sentiamo giocare
quindi alla fine eravamo qui da pochi
problemi oggi gioco ma dai ma qua quasi
non è da praticamente in praticamente no
però aveva un bel d'età adesso è caduto
ma no c'è che ti aggravato di milo che
ci penso io diventi ripari oggi non fare
cadere stare a casa e sociale da solo
perché poverino
poi vedi caro etica il papero mi editore
ci vado addosso anch'io dov'è dove è
caduto mi sa che è caduto pure lui
perché è sparito maledizioni si e nella
zona blu veronica ti saluto non è però
anche vero che ha lo scatto perfetto
allora next one è tanto sono veloce ma
niente brut bruttissima con quella
sindaco che sono messo solo perché nuova
rotta amico terribile però lei le ricche
brutta che effettivamente non è il
massimo quindi rimasto solo leo
no solo di chi sono io come solo gli
oracoli se li avete fatto e sono morti
tutti il papa non ha fatto mai uniti lo
è nel pablo è detta addio
cos'è sta roba apex legends magica
questa è la hope sinesi che era l'unica
mappa in team che sapevo fare me l'hanno
cambiata adesso saranno tutti dei day di
babbi
lo so che non va piano piano il solo è
il solo e in solo meno male che cosa
devo fare qua a non prendere se i costi
be cosi ok va bene i dolci
come non ci sono salito poco dio e si va
via ma in una società che c'è 110 viola
giallo e poi puoi muovere questi cosi
gialli agli per spostare deve arrivare
devi prendere tv e scusami ma che c'è il
tempo come sono i primi tre di ciò che
prendono i suoi cerchi a ok a piano
toglie gente no se tu non arrivi tra i
primi 13 poi non ti qualifichi luce
quello d'ora a in mezz'ora di eden una
faccia arrivarci ragazzi ora che casino
non si capisce una sega li aspetta
migliorato l'addio arriva il cube il
cubo o risposta è sì allora mentali ma
cosa me ne frega a me ma cosa vuoi
dai non ci credo come ho fatto non
prenderlo questo dai nove puntate due
normali ma direi che se no no però c'è
questo paga che sono di punta a lui mai
attivo come quello questo era il mio ama
alcuni valgono doppio
ma quelli d'oro anche no non li prendo
ragazzi non ci arriva
non ci arrivava ed è perché il costo di
risposta la rampa d'accesso sottoposto
da questa roba santissimo gesù ok
togliti dai mate cadere uno qua che
cacchio io se stavo fermo un'ora fa
guardala te lo voglio questo no
la gamma veramente ai ragazzi un
buongiorno 111 semplice punto uno
semplice io ci metto la piattaforma live
dai prezzi non ho fatto raiatea
affanculo che almeno mi sono sacrificato
non vuoi andare tutti o mancati qua
tutti o magari non mi meritavo niente ma
fanno tanto la metà eliminati non mi
meritavo nulla che parco sta partito va
bene allora carino insomma e carichi
lavori o meno male che sei da solo
perché se fossi in team io avrei già
uccidimi compagni quindi meglio così no
però ragazzi è stata una roba veramente
un parto tik tok questa guerra ma
mutandoni colori puri e quasi ma io
posso fare
ma perché hanno capito i colori e si sa
se le piattaforme 13 gb per questo c'è
il tragico valore reginato tre cose 13
10 giga saranno i crediti però aspetta
vediamo un attimo allora quindi non sono
ovviamente i rossi volevano solo messo
le texture a caso vediamo se fate ha tra
l'altro si vede il colore diverso però
non hanno messo la cosa che va 230 spect
dell'amico a non ce la fanno
era vero con l'anomalia e no altri 4 gb
però anomala o meglio veramente a palla
una saturazione ragazzi ma dai ma è
veramente incredibili colori sono stati
fatti per ogni caghaz mille per la
donazione veronica grazie cara ci sia
buona contrasta bonati qua sotto
se vuoi abbonarti persone vari tears di
quello che vuoi vai avanti zio
abbi coraggio nella tua vita fa in
azione buona fa la fa la palla non la fa
guarda il papero maledetto quello che
era davanti a me bravo e ragazzi fino
alla fine è continua e ancora non è un
eliminato incredibile ora felice dei che
volevano essere
di ogni palla finale spero se la mappa
nuova quindi veramente in finale ci sono
ex con a
mi hanno detto che hanno cambiato
hexagon che l'unica che sapevo fare bene
quindi mi metti di colori delle
piattaforme ma speriamo di no non ci
pensino e non capisco niente
sono passati a rombi dai secoli spero
che abbiano ridotto il problema che
passi in mezzo alle celle sembra uguale
ragazzi però non so vediamo adesso che
carica oddio come così che ho cambiato
le cose
io io veramente ragazzi non so piùa di
nava su se il colore il pattern battere
più bello e perfetto meno male neanche
la finale e anche api non puoi neanche
permetti di spezzarla
mi aspetto il papero maledetto perchè
gli auguro le peggio cose mentre giorni
l'altro c'era piattaforma gialla sopra
sotto accennata ciò non si capisce
niente perché ci sono due piattaforme
colore uguale c'è veramente orribile per
pieni del mariani nel male in fondi
l'abbiamo votato quella sotto
praticamente sì è stata una roba
inguardabile come comunque ora grazie a
chiara fortissimo perché la gente nel
raggio delle rompermi le scale quello
che tutto il popolo adesso no è la
iniziato è caduto giù a nessun caduto è
caduto giù delle schiacciate chi sono ma
spoleto nation cara benvenuta in giacomo
sisters of luck e da come gioca stoppa
ho sbagliato io sono di ragazze
sbagliato io ho fatto una cagata
ok detto solo gente che corre quindi
gente che hanno iniziato a giocare oggi
ma l'animazione che la guerra formava
leggermente in basso chelsea no non
c'era un mese se c'è una prima non era
roba che la piattaforma pavé leggermente
in basso così prima no non c'era lo
garantisco che non c'era questo papero
incredibile quello più in alto di tutti
ragazzo tranquillo sta correndo correndo
questa è la cosa vergognosa
cioè se giocasse con calma sarà un bari
nato che correva fi con saltati con
leggerezza se non ad essa è caduta
caduto di due piattaforme e alla sua
piattaforma sia il blu verde c'è bisogno
che lui c'è blu e rosa fare niente mi sa
che posso solo non andare dove va all
altra gente cosa che sarebbe molto si
comunque hanno messo piattaforme uguali
sopra e sotto si capisce ecco il povero
occhio accaduto caduto lega l'ultima
lezione che glie l'ho chiamato chiedevi
scassare le scatolame ok niente almeno
in via addosso a me per carità non
andare da sempre era l'ultima questa
peccato siamo nelle mani del signore
ok
qua si sta isolando malissimo
io vorrei che il rischio
sto facendo ma perché coglie l'ultima
piattaforma e ho sbagliato ragazzi ho
sbagliato io non so che di soldi giocata
male giocata male però peccato perché
c'era il popolo padano che comunque è
morto il padre ho giocato proprio male
io ha vinto un altro principio ha vinto
lo sporco ha vinto vinto la corona però
non so per quale motivo allora va bene a
livello è sì perché a livello di dan
ancora sì sì sì da una corona beh ho
sbagliato ho sbagliato io ragazzi gigi
gigi dai next next eccolo questo fare
meglio si può fare di meglio ma i
ragazzi fate red pie
rip con le due finali su due euro uguale
prima cioè non c'è almeno hanno cambiata
ed ex non milano mi dice nulla è la
nuova asta mappa comunque non potevo
saperne nulla effettivamente balene di
chi volendo ama la vittoria sta
nell'ordine di quel paperone del papero
più che altro io odio le persone di club
hanno altre persone
volevo niente si è ovvio con tutto me
stesso perché quella persona che
grappolo silente sono io quindi tu hai
abbiamo io una corona di base con questa
skin effettivamente avete ragione che
però ancora non può farlocca certe
guardate non è proprio una corona non ha
potuto scambiare dell'antico carriero
dai chiare in questa va bene 57 su 60 il
momento di fare la partita giusta
peccato perché non si poteva fare dorme
o finalmente idealmente moglie i colori
qua cambiano speriamo che gli voglio
partire primo solo per beccare la prima
porta sbagliata perché tutto succederà
menti che hanno iniziato la roba no raga
non ci annuncia quello che basano la
propria propensione risiamo
e se ne va tra l'altro credo sia un pò
in discesa sono io ma boh vediamo
no scherzo non sembrava in discesa
by step restituta avanti a me io so che
sceglierà divario dagli usa michael
bravo
bravo solo quella sera io stesso mi fido
perché tanto tu non hai dead della mia
sfiga e noi dobbiamo fidarci a vicende
ragazzini sono quel casino forza forza
forza e vai vai contro la porta
ok perfetto nokia si era sparato addosso
non mi perdere qui all'inizio non provo
si parla di tutto questo casino e poi
magari perdo io quindi non ci passi da
santa veronica perché vide giacomo
carrara grazie mille ma quante veroni
che ci sono nella propria mente però se
non ti chiami veroli che non puoi
guardarla live perché non ti fai
scrivere ti fai scriver ma poi ci sono
le 2 mila cani mai pagato i suoi
aderenti al traguardo che ha pagato
ieri però del genere ma prima pole al
senato prima di potersi a per ultimo va
bene va bene non è stata cosa non hanno
ancora tutto c'è ha aggiunto la roba che
anche se lefty rimani nel tabellone
quella roba lì credo e poi magari mi
sbaglio non c'erano troppi buchi vuoti
infatti speriamo ben rollout che non ha
ancora fatto sarebbe quella delle asce
che tutti dicono che nuova e difficile
quelle bella quella difficile lourival l
acer l'ha provata stamattina è bella
difficile quella a ok ok vediamo
attenzione trappole come li ma siamo
pure i gialli perdiamo che non lo siamo
noi e almeno siamo noi noi e qualche
anno è vero vero siamo tra di noi quindi
possiamo solo tra gli altri non fanno
schifo
possiamo solo perdere mano del più
arancione uova su un piano razionale
speedo se il vaccino dei pregi di si
butta sul moderato non comprende ripreso
yo yo yo fammelo prendere gli ho
sbattuto contro martello mie compagne mi
sbattono addosso hanno fatto niente
chiaramente hanno remixato crazy frog
raga
guarda che è partito un nuovo dorato in
aria non ho idea di che se qua niente
tornato in mezzo io vado a sabotare gli
altri perché se no perché io difendo ce
la fa ma qua pontida e gialli ios
insaputa di tutti i più accesi assaltato
di questo ragazzo puzzle arrivo rigore
che già li hanno tre uova d'oro quindi
gli omini gialli i gialli sono pagati
dice che andrà come mai non hanno riso
ai punti assolutamente tutti contro di
lui è perché siamo quelli che hanno meno
ma guarda che quei gialli non ha nessuno
ne hanno più
togliete i già e togliete le uova gialle
ai gialli capito io sto difendendo
provvedere perché se no no va bene va
troppo di missione vado emissione come
mai difendere non è un problema non lo
difendo dimissioni sto togliendo tutte
le foto che riescono e difendete raga
programma davvero tantissimi peso vai
vai mai ci sono tra solo un giallo che
difendere sfiga è solo un giallo che
difende 6 blu avessero un minimo di
cervello andrebbero conti all'ingrato
datemi una mano lega il blu raga non
sanno giocare dovrebbero andare contro i
gialli che sono in minoranza
capisco perché sono contro i rossi aveva
tutto è uomo di blu non sanno giocare
ragazzi ci hanno 34 ma non sa non si
meritano niente di nuovo ma ci stanno
dando forte state difendendo ragazzi non
fate una nuova già ride sopra di peso
per il mondo sotto perché il mio
compagno rosso micra ba togliti ok a
posto ma lui non sapevano giocare hanno
salvato i primi inclusi assurdo prove
curatissima questa mamma mia è normale
molto sudata ma carina
la con questa attività fisica la donna è
scomodissimo i ragazzi infatti non me la
sento che fa perno prove va bene papà
nuova di provola ora cosa ma vincere non
solo dai militati gialli sinistra anche
la slide klein veramente spalle perché
sempre questo non lo possiamo creare
l'amalgama tinte non soffre seoline
clive tra tutte con glassatura tissima
palla anche tanti occhi di tutti e
quattro sì se siete così affrontare il
cuscino raga perché io ormai vivo fino
appunto perché avete votato lo punto
troppo casino ragazzo bravo bravo nichi
vai vai vai vai vai vai vai per non
rischiare non lo puntata a ronco raga
occhio l'altro tronco rango idra altro
arbitro questo ma preso vahidi è il
momento
vai di al momento perfetto per coop
riscatto in cui schifare visto come ho
fatto e non lo sapevo ma neanche io vado
alloggi ok anche qua verità eccoci
problemi come questi ha messo mano tu
sei avanti o che chi fa il martello si
sa mai mamma mia
questo quindi la domanda lo faccio ok no
è stata mai mi ha superato torna qui
raggiunti cos'ha fatto
speriamo vi leggiamo no ma perché è mio
con da perché murray
by step primo bravo però la gente ma vai
vai non sei arrivato intensa ha
criticato il primo per acchiappare la
piena facciamo qui va bene meno gente me
la gente ecco questo questo è il tutto
questo è un doppio che arriva proprio
dallo ju vorrebbe solo la punta 18 20
casa 69 è salvato
non so come siamo in venti giorni
il nostro ha chiesto rischiando chi ha
sbagliato secondo butti non butti
sbagliato un amplificato lasciatelo
stare no pulisce ma poi è caduto sulle
voglio fare leo contro questo mai mai
mai detto no no no perché mi tiene
quello di adesso questo è il bambino
farà la vocata alla mappa prima di
entrare perché otto anni guarda il pre
la previsione l'altro il casco da boxeur
e la gonnellina c'è qualcosa che non va
nel outfit però per campo numeri ma la
modalità nuova quale ai ragazzi che non
ho capito niente che mi dava selezionare
tra sei giorni però ma cos'è boh non si
è capito se permetti può solo una
modalità sotto il tempo tra ok se non
aveste strana oppure ti mette sulle
mappe nuove che però sono 45 conto che
mi sembra strano anche a me quello è
finalmente più parti bene qua è finita
qua già ragazzi io ho visto il glitch di
come salire sul blocco alla fine e lo
vuoi provare a fare il ci provo va bene
sai già la corona perché non lo farò mai
perché qua ormai il body collision ti
butta giù come niente quindi speriamo
ecco devo fare quello che ho fatto sulla
testa di stef devo farlo quando ci sono
i blocchi però ma devi stare sopra un
altro male ma ben che hanno messo l'anno
hanno tolto delle altre mappe per
metterle secondo me no no ed è quello il
problema
chi mentre tipo quello del memory non
l'hanno tolta scrollando quelle che
potevano capitare che disaster taglie
dyer a quella con le asce dovrebbe
capita all'inizio perché tipo ma te ne
sei praticamente se infatti torre
veramente a lei mega rotation sono pazzi
a non averla messa
già ma gli dovevo spiegare come si fanno
i giochi noi invece rimaniamo un'e mail
non so veramente ragazza ok io lo so che
per questa cosa che ho fatto l umorismo
aggrappato neo aggrappato leo e niente
ragazzi beni chi ci vogliamo una
prossima partita
quindi devo america ma sta dicendo
niente malata perché disattivato mica
come sta studiando la la nostra
soprattutto con stef soprattutto su sky
vivo lo ha sbattuto sull'interno mi ha
piazzato
no mi è riuscito ma dai vabbè che
cacchio da vedere se della disinstallato
per l'invito ma perché mi deve uscire
niente noi posso vedere lega ma nella
chiesa finale va beh niente prova
con occhi per tutto il tempo non ci ho
fatto hanno messo quanto 5 ma per il
resto pare bella la season dove mai
fatti ragazzi ma sono fatti ma perché
perché stare perché questa cosa hanno
fatto una pazzia totale da matti sono i
12 che la di non c'è più come faglie
attive 12 che siete imprese privati che
abbiamo fatto i nomi possono anche
vedere la gara che cosa sia la finale
così finiamo in fretta mio problema
posso
se togliamo il monte da jean shodown
anche questa è nuova
nove i comuni sono cambiati di cap and
jump showdown i colori modificati o mio
perdendo una roba incretino melo la rava
averci separato le asce ma dopo non ci
voglio credere
il figlio di manieri fu la prova a farne
una per vedere come madonna di malati
sai che comunque è più veloce parte più
veloce ferrero alla fine è vero sì
l'unica modifica fisi
abbiamo creato 700 mega hanno messo
finora check up sodano ok la prima
modifica di mezzi che va bene ma non è
ma solo crepa massimo io almeno della
vittoria non so cosa si trova almeno
l'incidente da se hanno tolto anche la
cosa che quello che rimane su una
piattaforma da solo marche 6 carretto
step
no ancora no grazie prego prego per ora
abbastanza mamma mia non è che stiamo
rischiando pochissimo
questa qua crolla secondo me c'è un dio
chi ha vinto ma con la mente a nessuno
il momento critico è oscillata però
questa come parte italiano e abbiamo
paura di questo sono arrivato secondo in
quella che non male ma verrete capitata
a quella delle altre ma delle ascese
bella vera bella fatta questa vera e
propria novità e capita più spesso mai
hai mai fatti c'è
mannaggia alla prossima più spesso nei
nuovi generale madonna che casino che la
gente creata vabbè ma la gente è
diventata bravissima siamo davvero
ancora 10 minuti a modino cento siamo 4
con due piattaforme siamo così diamo un
botto ma l'arbitro come fa rimane sempre
lì e problemi a devi calmarti ragazzi
stati tritata malissimo e sta partita
quando questa brutta brutta da grandi
laga anche questa è brutta noises
all'arbitro sempre lì rimane però i
nostri ragazzi ma sta generando più
lentamente per la partita non è vero
infatti tabella adesso valente era
giusto per fare dieci minuti iniqua ma
io muoio rialzati oddo prima mi ha preso
il gatto mannaggia che nel cascato
siamo vivi non sa ancora quanti ce ne
aspettiamo noi utenti
io voglio adesso o che altri due altri
tre altri 3 3 contro 3
si deve vincere l'italia germania e non
c'è più e l'arbitro abbiamo sbagliato
ok non mi ha dato
è bellissima sembra di vedere le partite
di calcio dalla radio nessuno mi ha
afferrato stesso il miracolato confermi
gli è caduto
nessuna siamo pronti costante il
miracolo o crollo le piattaforme a noi
non ce l'andiamo città rimane costante
ragazzi venuti dalla piattaforma 11 30
la rapida e costante 9 devi provare st
finale una maratona valorizzano quelli
che gravano si fa mistero di resistenza
né tantomento 6 ore ragazze non erano
aumenta la velocità è sempre uguale
ma allora scusa quando finisce girando
l'italia di domani sarà eliminato ma le
ho portato via uno come dire ad attuare
mi è rimasto io steffen altro dai siamo
due su tre dai vedere vincere si sa
quanto mi sto agendo per roverelli
intervenire mannaggia
quanto deve reggere nelle sedi finché
non ti distrai leogra palo che la
balocco lo stop allo sport grappa
l'altro che vince stefano
no
cosa sta succedendo clicca il maratoneta
devi star carlo dell'altra video quello
dopo la targa che si salta salta bravo
ma c'è un ma è veramente razza e un
magico quanto dura infinita che io sono
in finale quattro volumi crescono resi
con finale vanno in continuamente ad
android
dimmi che porta niente che vivono e
muoiono niente lavoro
un'amara che voleva le sei molto per un
ninja mia una maratona è sfiga la è
bella per oggi girolamini ha vinto la
piena solo lei
io ho fatto la soup l'ex nel time alti
come la durata 6 ore sta partita vostra
minuti fatemi arrivata temi cinque
minuti che tipicamente sono in finale
anch'io cioè le mie mani da ieri dal tar
o questa è la finale dopo che siamo in
25 di molti allora questa quella di
prima regala devo saltare nei cerchi
vediamo se scappa sei cosi perchè il
premio ma per io me so così intimi
questa pensavo con all old man alone in
the dark blue bene cioè molto meglio di
alimentare la sua materia che così non
deve spaccare il joystick
se davvero come mai avere il tempo di
muovergli le pedane
da quello che sento che una sfruttavano
kemalismo con gli altri
questa nessuno muove nulla nessuno
proveniente sempre da un po il passo
yes e guardati in faccia un attimo come
poi dice allora io ho 36 la china
vichingo e da giullare che sono carine e
beveva vacillare le gare che bella bella
il bello che non come con diversamente i
cinesi non puoi stare in mezzo perché ci
sono sì così si alzano maledetti fregato
bella quella del vichingo del viking a
top bellissima
sinceramente no no red bar forward
bellissimo cacchio non ha saltato
arrivare prima di questa area c è un
anno è un'ansia arrivare primi in questa
non si può proprio yes and last one il
trio ritiro via questo è accaduto perché
gli occhi o nel caso quello che gli ho
tirato via la rampa reso bene allora
5 su 15 e poi andiamo direttamente alla
final allora che non esca titolo ma
spero io non sono così vedere quali già
più show down ma l'aquila ha cambiato
totalmente papa frate state prese anche
con l'altra
perché mai nulla e c'è nulla forse i
colori delle piattaforme e basta va bene
non aziza ma mancano ancora sette
persone quella che ci mettono un
bordello questi qua a fare che ti puoi
fare un caffè nel frattempo grazie a the
nation a file casi è rara il problema di
questa mappy problema di ste robe qua e
che veramente non possono essere 100
persone a lavorare a chi ha fatto i
mediatori come nessuno ha detto no
magari facciamo un pò più di cinque
mappe nuove per la nuova sito che poi
non ci vuole molto per fa una mappa già
adesso va bene tutto non so
programmatore ma che cacchio cioè che ci
vuole
adesso perché l'ho già lavora season 3
vecchio radio rientra come fa a
formentera ben quattro mani e volto a
illuminazione però farà questo che è
passato che col ok ragazzi che vi devo
dire vediamo ma una finale nuova c'è o
no perché dove no non c'è una finale
nuova ditte via pure di no che gli usa
volevano di sì speriamo no io lo spero
per loro che è tristissimo non avere
linkano fino alla nuova ma in faccia
almeno è ciò che hai fatto due mapperà
magari hanno sostituito quella della
coda
per lavorava le parole rame la parola
tutto sto casino poi metà player
eliminati effettivamente però se tu ci
metti se sei primo in questa mappa qua
da vinci poi posare joystick e andare a
b c è davvero a fare con la cacca tanto
questi per fare fuori tutto ci mettono
un ora va bene proviamo
no ma veramente ex crumble in 15 ma
siete pazzi
no voglio fare strambo io penso di fare
la fine direttamente cioè pensate
proviamo anche perché i miei compagni
sanno come sempre stupidi e comunque
escono sempre le stesse incredibile
quello non cambia mai però anche avviato
le musiche di sottofondo le sento
diverso
innanzitutto dice gb il problema è che
se quando un calo di players poi diventa
veramente difficile gestirla per loro
perché se poi fanno devono tenere punto
devono tener botta adesso dovevano
mettere gli impostori diamo un gas
madonna si è molto critica sanno però
benz atto va bene allora le uova sono
qua vediamo se le scale vaglierà i
gialli protegge il nuovo d'oro fa bene
gli oli tiro fuori tutte le altre però
per loro vista fermi
c'è qui lui è fermo sullo roma nessuno
se lo sta cagando volume a loro poi si
troverà solo col pomodoro in mano da
solo niente però è pettinari atto non so
se devo andare sui gialli o forse i blu
hanno non lo so perché entrambi stanno
andando giunta che si difendono principe
già lì il principe che già li eleva
devoluto non sanno di niente
hai tolto pure quello che teneva loro
dorato in credenze non cela capi lui
bello che non è la punta lenta che
buttano fuori mi restano fissi a 8
adesso ha capito che non può farci
quindi tutta fermarmi geni
un oro è tanto la preso un altro
italiano lo stato e la tattica migliore
questa raga non ce ne è la tattica
migliore che lo dico se ci fosse se
fossimo in due a fare questa cosa
sarebbe ancora meglio va bene last one
tavolate speriamo di fare un un
hexagonal meno perché sono almeno un
extra con radio però in dieci poi il
monte non c'ho voglia riprovano formate
in un film on the wall mount enough al
monte uscito dove furono perdiamo ed
esco mi raccomando è l'ultima lei ma
fino alla fine anche se parti
quindicesimo quindicesimo su 12 12 fino
alla fine di mi raccomando nessuno puoi
fare tu lo puoi fare
va bene va bene poi mental coach mental
coach come esatto andrà promozione solo
sugli altri come non funziona mai tu non
puoi fare tu mi guardo allo specchio
dicono si farà in uno scherzo dai
comunque se stesso sarà per forza
secondo me hanno fatto partire dietro e
che grazie al cacchio
attenzione però a niente ma hanno spinto
ma scritto tanto non l'ha presa nessuno
perché il tipo non l'ha toccata la data
uno che non la palesemente non l'ha
toccata mi ha spinto il martello avessi
capito che tanto sta facendo non ci
spero nemmeno mission prove siamo l'ex
tante palle lati in via lievitate vivo
ai ragazzi che è capitato arriva al 14 e
mappe 9 15 st quella dei cinesi
poi francesco voi come inneggiavano caro
a quella delle asce e devo ancora vedere
la speriamo che esca come prima perché
sono curioso e lei è bella e l'ho vista
prima mostra le dico basta volerle
intensamente le cose vedi lorenzo un po
il monte in forma perfetta hit parade
allora il pareggio poi dopo le volte
saturata magrini la mia penso che
abbiamo aumentato associazioni di tutto
questo punto non a singola mappa perché
tutto saturato quindi non ai locatori
che si rincontrano costituzionale in
questa nuova season maturià satura di
viola nella saturazione a turiamo alla
season 3 diventa lietamente un sole
delle skin e iniziano a cantare ma
infatti ragazzi non ho capito sesta
stagione
se hanno fatto ma l'obiettivo è far
uscire le mappe pian piano sono
veramente questi si sino ai poliziotti
ne sono altri che lo sì però
ciao a tutti ne mettono per quello il
fatto che le maglie di stanca prima
certo bello ribassi vero per favore mi
servirebbero come è bellissimo vedere
benissimo soci spinare fortissimo
matarazzo io vedevo lo stesso e
camminare con i gomiti sullo slime
saliva in esame resasco prima e
abbordabili da vicino da lo lasciai non
doveva essere la prova forse anche la
seconda cioè perché non è comunque
lascia l'hanno messa al posto del della
mappa delle rampe perché io non ho mai
visto che la mappa stamattina è prima
alla prima cena prima ci speravi si
sperava nel muro ecco quelle l'altra
nuova di quelle di scalare i muri cioè
che non ho mai visto non civile maria
anche quota attenzione best male se non
si vede neanche ci sono scarsi qui hanno
cambiato la frutta abbiamo messo anche
il cocco ligure e giurie jazz ghiacciate
che perde nesta rai magari allora ci
sono quattro grandi invece che 3 a
speriamo visto che proprio la mente
della mappa se però potevano far
qualcosa anguria ciliegie
ok andiamo onesto bene la bella è bella
questa mappa da vedere un sacco di gente
cosa succede quando le relazioni ora i
futuristi
mamma mia ok da questo livello io sto
attaccato alla tiber che io non mi
ricordo nulla
i nomi crollare del tanto di gravose
mitraglia
e tranquillo no no non mi ha risposto
questo non mi piace per niente e non ti
disparate vi sta concentrando equa tra
tutti vanno gli la aspetta
meno male ma per correre non mi sembra
male ma previsto come sono arrivato
sulla piattaforma per casa
scherza pieno come quello che voglio la
celebra tutti oggi riaprono tantissimo
no no no basta regolare identica bella
bella come hanno messo semplicemente
piattaforme che rimangono un po prima di
comparire ottimo andamento è la vedrà a
vico prime pgt dai dai ne so che sarà
questa questa è stata tutorial per
giocare quando escono le mappe dai
adesso c'è adesso arrivano da sarebbe
questa la nuova queste quella nuova no
vediamo come si gioca lazio ne sbatte
quello che in via sono emozionato
finalmente le nuove mappe poi non ne ho
fatta una nuova hanno cambiato i colori
dei lollipop però attenzione perché
questo questo è importante che con che
lo vedrebbe lo vedo bene la hd quindi
quei 3 4 100 mega lollipop praga è stato
molto bello giocare insieme a voi va
bene hanno niente di noi ci proviamo
ok
fatto anche lo script del cuscino e
tutto questo solo una parte no ma domani
davanti a tutti per aver investito
attenzione tenta lo skipper faro cade
rovinosamente ancora proprio lui mai
[Musica]
finto ghiacciate che so mascara la
donazione all'orale tu io odio e malia
libero non non ci arriva subito un terno
al lotto ii no no no no non lo sapesse
quindi noti siti eliminato accaduto ma
dai leo insiste loschi pino ok esistendo
le ho visto ragazzi occhio dei tomi
spinge tutti a mazzo così ci siamo
latini limiti massimi
questo quanto questo regge no non ci
credo
la scimmia prodotto spingerlo di pa non
essendo mi devi toccare non mi nemico
non eliminiamo fin qui gli allarmi ma
lei mi erano monaco sempre non mollarlo
[Musica]
vabbè passo rolle questo ma è passato
molto dire un tango vista mi molla e
pazzo mi piacciono i pirati con dio
sembra quasi al traguardo ma la vicenda
damigella aiutami a non pagato di ormai
da tempo gli occhi occhio
alto arrivando lo slide non ha paura ma
dai ma che i problemi aveva poi rimasto
un unico malato di mente insulta la
lobby bellissimo bellissima adesso se
hugo mini game perché appena esco fuori
sei mesi la produzione guarda noi se c'è
uno dei muri di ex alunni nei sei in 16
semi ma mai successo a sta cosa e dici
mi sembra esagerato bellissimo va bene è
molto esagerato chi quindi tutti fra le
stesse sono io io e quelli non abbia
tutta forma vicino le tue a destra anime
vedrai al fatto di sottodiciotto quelle
cast americano non parla e non può non
correre cosa corli che sei da solo non
poteva succedere questa cosa
bene brother ma perché la gente mi corre
in faccia salta non sai giocare a questo
gioco non giocare giocare altra roba
giocava call of duty non sono giocar
polgai posso dirvi che questo effetto
del blocco che scompare fa proprio
schifo si sino al mi piace non mi piace
veramente la chiama perché la città di
corato a matera per niente testata
nucleare che ci ho tirato non so cosa
dirvi morto anche sto gioco l'unica tema
essere ci stava ma non capisco neanche
come posso provare a finirla perché
nella gente mi corrado neanche se sei
ninja convincerla micco al caso perché
la gente mi cadendo non posso fare
niente e grima cosa dirmi ragazzi mi
sono impegnato al massimo
io sono rimasta lì della città di che
doveva ammazzare che pensate a uscita e
prego che era un rito da vincerla una
volta su due ha non toccarla
vabbè ma di ma quando sia in 16 non è
neanche da tenere in considerazione con
veramente possibile io come giocare a
calcio in un campo normale in 42 contro
la signora e byron un'altra mamma mia
asca audio per arrecare altri video che
questa roba è veramente abominio
ferragamo a prendere l'acqua arrivò
subito
volevo invitare gianpi ma non certo
comunque adesso sono morto non lo urlano
troppo ma se molto male ero il più alto
di tutti sono caduto tipo di cinque
piattaforme il bug della piattaforma
sull'ultimo no a me no ma ha fatto mi fa
caldo perché l'altra gente fa cosa non è
tanto paga non faceva qui però non ho
capito bene se è dovuto alla patch o no
questi capolisti cavoli e pro su una
finale no il bug quello delle
piattaforme ma perché non lo risolvi
cosa si so non lo so lo so certo risolto
neanche quello mastra ma secondo me i
ragazzi stanno adesso entro stasera ne
escono commenti altre mappe e dicono no
scherzavo come la mamma mi ha detto che
sfiga la sempre nel cavaliere cavaliere
si apre sabato sera va bene ai facile e
difficile duke è affatto sarà la
duchessa anche che porta male io voterò
tantissimo quando so già perché gli ma
sicuramente scalzo bastard applicazioni
specchi dal fratello torna quando hai
fatto 340 vittorio veneri parliamo
adesso nella canzone anche forse neanche
leggere
vamos queste capitali una meta già lo so
volete infezioni vip dio dog che ce l'ho
fatta mamma mia che culo ma è cascato in
un buchino che poi tanto sta mappa
infame perché vedi di booking non non
esiste
potevo è bellissimo è veramente belle
salute per iniziata per la rete
incredibile questa qua ragazzi è
veramente l'unica cosa aveva senso che
per ora ha veramente un segnanome si
legge è bella quella nuova donna che si
chiama
qualcosa navy seal non mi fate cadere
ciao porca miseria noi aspettiamo il
timing del suo crudo di lato una pensata
equa devi prendere il tempismo
giustissimo più sino nome ragazze corri
tutto ad essere più facile come facevamo
noi di fare questa cosa abbassa let's go
fratelli non ce la faccio lasciare
andato anche io che ho detto abbiamo
tempismo sbagliato bene ciao dati
qualcosa mi ricordo che si chiama con la
quale quella nuova che hanno fatto così
lei però non è utile di madonna che sta
a fare la prima un affare è legale ma
bellissimo dovrebbero farle tutte il 24
così gli piace le hanno cambiate 4 poi
qualificati e si qualifica di wuxi
legends di legends apex legends esatto
forse per quello che avevi detto sì
questo no questo non è a ok ok non è
passata una gara no perché ha fatto
delle cose che male ragazzi legend sono
strana però vabbè dai che arriva la
prima vittoria di oggi che cacchio
speriamo che riesca a te spero gli ex
riesca extra con perché
dai errori hexagon pero negli extra che
sto dicendo niente lei ex post ma in
quanti siamo noi siamo in tantissimi
ancora i alexa.com è scesa la mia non
perfetta ma 59 52 e viene una cosa
incredibile per da ex con i 200 pro
l'auto risulta più dunque quello di 200
le palle rollout mamma mia
odio sia stata tarata dalla data datata
comunque la duchessa come skin mi fa un
po cacare ragazzi prova vero teniamo
finché non arriva quella nuova perché
non so quale sara ai due prima l'ho
preso
ebbene sì ma per averla perché comunque
la legendary capito è importante avere
legge
no no no no questo manca la foto mi ha
fatto cadere anche a me stanno
strappando problema dove io odio odio la
gente che grab atroce basterà fare è
vecchia a giocà a qualcos'altro brutto
stupide idiota ma se come accaduto che
un cretino
dopo mi stanno lo dico a 10 fps
e che mi aggrappato prima questo nuovo
il cappellino questo qua quel cappellino
ma garbato di caprino sia scaduto
no io sono caduto io sono già caduto da
prima ok mi ha fatto vedere proprio
perché ho visto telebari teano era tanto
col cappellino chiamato a boss per 25 m
3 mining comunque come roma è strano
perché non arriva mai 25 non può
cambiato gli eliminati ogni minima fa
strano ma parlava fosse stata la parola
6 sclerato malissimo ma neanche i colori
hanno cambiato tavolo svanisse macchina
stato di aree scrive simone al con la h
sulla va bene quaranta minuti di
applausi per i ragazzi sembra giusto
altro c'è una propria alto tag uguale
però nel sesso aiuta anche la cena 6 10
8 22 10 8 ma è vero questo qua il
piccione che ci può essere solo uno così
io dice la presidente avete fatto
l'account a venti secondi di distanza
l'uno dall'altro la propria che due di
seguito dei fatti e come beccare due
macchine con
la barca de la barca si diversa di un
numero anzi no e ancora perché poi è
globale la situazione invece per le
macchine potrebbe essere fattibile
perché comunque antico d'italia
l'altro non so se hai notato ma tu non
passi sotto il caso rosa infatti guarda
che ti passa sopra la testa ti si piega
il collocate a ok ok
buono a sapersi ho grande camon
a
15 hexagon quindi potrebbe mettere anche
proprio no no il gran ball matite che
sono molto alle pre fill e rock and roll
va bene siamo tutti siamo in due io non
ci sono
spingi altro perché mission caro lo
spingi al dr
spingi alto uno strumento lo spingi e lo
spingi aldo palmas
ho visto tanti dell'orco come fai avere
già al nord ma si può sciupare il batter
il il pass si compasso no allora ci ha
giocato 200 ore solo oggi questa è una
sala in dell'orco che comunque la
sblocchi avanti del bacino quanto non mi
ricordo in eventi di veli fai veramente
fast e allora può essere che da
stamattina si è però se hai giocato la
stamattina fall guys non sei tanto a
posto dove sarà posto però vabbè dai e
che ci avete fatto si liberò antico ma
chi era via mare che lui è uno che ne fa
questa qua paesi è tranquilla potete
anche lasciarla gg faccio comunque fino
a caso gallinetta per me stanno facendo
sia dato un peso non sta partita vediamo
un attimo è sì sì blu fatto perdere ma
scusate raga non so per quale motivo
in dieci la di ses hexagon ex di fare
perché da esse 10 è fattibile di
accettura io spero di essi riescano a
hexagon no al monte con la guarda
neanche sul monte sa che sfiga parti
davanti però la troverà in nero sono
partito l'avana almeno quello fa il bis
e 6 anche a destra quindi buon leo
nazionale invece tutto a sinistra
cosa come e fatto arrivare lì l'auto
l'altro non solo kakà mi vedo ancora
rotolare io m3 sali attivato iac questa
fase sarà tratta mia miseria è un
partito che a destra ragazze un cazzo
fai che però può sempre perdere il tempo
ok niente strategy nei come
passato come potuto vincerlo
eccolo qua l'orco che dicevamo prima
velocista via ma che bella salentina
emeralds in flux legend che lo fa è
partito qua non si poteva io veramente
non è questa l'unica guarda potevano
anche fare invece che 24 mappe 23 ma
levare col monte che non ha senso è la
nuova comunque tavola si è usato in un
altro ci vuole dare in pasto a ecco
bravo e non ci vuole tanta al 10 e al 10
si allora niente
la ricordavo piovana e magari vengo 22
25 30 set
quanti la 5 corone quasi da un vichingo
belle
va bene il giullare di televisori 50
viste tutte leggevo palmos calcia
dell'isola scuole donation gara grazie
mille
speriamo di fare la partita dai scende
altrove di queste parti
ahia
ogni volta che dici parti primo party of
mountain esce col quantomeno definirà
venerdì va bene facciamo latanza antico
il monte in all'inizio mi mette a destra
posso anche in alto ad essa lo sa che
partiremo il monte comunque chi è che
aveva saltato l'ultima volta che ho
detto salta salta che poi era caduto e
non aveva aggravato in tempo a io io ero
io
cresce se si si ecco io vedo l'orco
aspettato un po nella tomovic e butta
secondo fare altro perché erano la
corona era subito giù a che non avevi
sbagliato niente ripartito più a destra
quindi tu ti sei seduto buttare come
l'orco è prenderlo perchè non l'hai
preso strano capito eh sì sì sì vabbè
non ha aspettato per niente lui non ha
aspettato
se no la prende con loro ho visto male
ora che quest'anno si alza che passo io
sapevo
ok
ho posizionato bene di antico che arrivò
primo ma secondo no io recto lato contro
cinquanta persone è arrivato bene però è
passato passato da grande che vangeli
live sono martedì giovedì e domenica
mattina trovate sul canale fino alle 13
oggi facciamo la rai pomeridiana che di
solito faccio la fine del mese ma l'ho
fatta oggi perché giustamente essendoci
al season 2 abbiamo sfruttato la rai
pomeridiana per fare la season dove
visto che comunque almeno la portavo in
live che comunque divertente
le mappe 9 specialmente le nuove
specialmente bellissimo delle altre robe
fighissime che non abbia ancora visto
tipo sfondare i muri over the world
league
niente ragazzi mettiamo delle mappe
nuove che però nessuno potrà mai giocare
ok è la bella onesta bella colorata
saturata è viva ragazzi disputeranno
rivedo di concorso se posso permettermi
di dirlo sono dei sia veloce felicissimo
sono dei pazzi perché allora ma per un
milione di motivi
e sbagliato fare solo quattro mappe c'è
la gente si aspetta una season uova sono
le stesse mappe di prima il gioco è
calato perché è calato ovviamente la
gente gioca sempre stesse cose o fai
delle mappe che quello non è che ti ci
devi rifare tutto il gioco da capo gli
asset ce l'hai
come hai fatto quelle della cia fa le
nuove parti e un mese ci metti per fare
una season secondo me né ai due tempo di
fare la sito la nuova
tu già adesso parti grazie già adesso
parti a fare la season 3 così e scena si
sono tre e ne escono tutte le mappe
nuove con l'assistente no non le
facciamo facciamo solo due mappe nuove
cioè che cosa acquisita si bevono
latisana tutti i giorni cioè nel senso
non stanno lavorando stanno a
sorseggiare tisana aromatica che cacchio
la file a fare io ragazzi se potesse
sapersi programmare dire oltre
prendete mi faccio io ci ho preso io
lardo di idee
se solo potessi fare voi che potete
farlo e non fate niente ma dai che
ridere un miliardo dei tempo ci sono
esistono un miliardo di cose labirinti
cose che il cadono dal miliardo se così
possono fare di finali vino rosso
ragazzi veramente non c'ho visto che ha
fatto hanno qualificato sta tagliando il
traguardo 1 mag rabato in un suo passato
vabbè poi mi battero giro ti stanno
succedendo tutte le cose che ho visto
ieri in un video di tipo troll su fall
guys tutte le cose che ho visto ieri
sono succede in questa altri visto che
io diciamo prima anche se lo prepariamo
al e volevo indugiarono caro questa sì
sono un bordello può che va a pezzetti
che emise musica e alcuni fix i quadri
bug penso che aggiungeranno altre mappe
le cose la si sono persone
allora poche mappe e vero estetiche
musicale con i bugfix li hanno fatti ok
su estetica e musica sono d'accordo e lo
e vedo il cambiamento ma non fa una
season il cambiamento nella texture lo
puoi fare uno può fare una patch è
normale una patch normale che cerchi un
giorno qualsiasi dice doveva fissato a
si hanno messo i colori un po più accesi
hanno cambiato due texture che è quella
è un update come un altro che uscire da
un giorno all'altro che non ha senso qui
quella non lo conto neanche come si sono
bugfix
non ne ho visti per ora non ho visto
mezzo bugfix perché leo è caduto nelle
piattaforme in mezzo alle celle
altri va bene non ho avuto pure quella
board esce che incarnasse che te lo
stradone a porta è volato leo quindi 22
banche su due li ha presi leone se no se
solo che prima sia colpa mia ho
sbirciato sul tuo personaggio è accaduto
ciò è colpa mia ma aprendo guarda che
caso pure io tanto ti preoccupare frate
quasi in compagnia come stavo dicendo
semmai il problema alla aggiungici il
problema del fatto che non hanno fissato
le cose principali è minimo
cioè non è una season cioè secondo me
devi aspettare un po di aspettare un po
e prenderle rom e nuove però
e averi che giocare a folgaria fa venire
caldo incredibile sto gioco che è
potenzialità che ha e una cimice liquido
che non capisco
jason kakà sembra donation calo già
provincia per merci
adesso ci proviamo ragazzi dovevano
fissare lo hanno fissare quello che
passa in mezzo alle celle quello che
quando cali dal condotti classifichi se
togli quando di buono si è classificato
setti disconnetti non comparire il
tabellone lì era sacrosanto non hanno
pensato
leo è schizzato malissimo di là entry le
partite lordi entravi di bugfix non ne
ho visti non ho visti in mezzo visto
mezzo i baffi anzi c'è un bagno in più
perché non ci facciamo arriva quindi un
bank in più i pro voce andranno bene
questa ripe quindi la roba nuova su
queste quattro mappe io però non ho
viste due quindi non so veramente altro
non l'hai mai non l'hanno già solo che
ci sono stai contro 99 è veramente poco
più non l'hanno neanche messi in
rotation esatto ecologico se loro
passion almeno almeno la rotation ma
neanche quella amara scusa comunque
stiamo giocando da due ore abbiamo
beccato due volte le mappe nuove bassi
non lo so questa quante 8 e la mobilità
ogni potere se ogni start praticamente
non l'hanno neanche messi non c'erano me
sei rotation ma non favorite io non ho
parole cioè la bella prova la base come
a questo punto mi chiedo è che comunque
è un'idea geniale come gioco come gli è
venuta sono regrediti dopo aver avuto
sfida geniale ma dai
allora se non è che scramble nuovo che
non capita mai che vi devo dire
dovrebbe capitare sempre una nuova sino
a quelle la season va fatta così nuova
season
ok almeno minimo ma minimo vuol dire che
poi se ti va male minimo la metà delle
mappe cambiate tutte minimo vorrei
capire tutte tutte se tieni alcune altre
mappe fai delle modifiche ma le tieni
con modifiche se non la cambierei tutte
24 tutte nuove tutte minimo minimo se
proprio non ce la fai almeno la metà
sono tutte nuove
è una cosa da mangiare buono questa
nuova zylon o quattro mappe in croce che
non escono e tra l'altro se ne metti se
le metti nuove le dodici nuovi elementi
tutti in rotation europa che quelle
altre vecchie non riescono mai almeno la
prima settimana ma è effettivamente c'è
nel senso sono poi come sei e un
ristorante fai un nuovo piatto però dove
mangia nessuno popolare
e veramente destra le modalità che
abbiamo provato 9 sono quelle della cia
è quella lì del lux idées modificata
all'ucsi legend secondo me va giù anche
adesso i giocatori non solo un anno a
season 3 perché adesso per aggregarsi
sono tre ci vogliono tre fermi felpe
cacchio tagli alla sanità che tra
l'altro allo stesso setup dell'altra 96
cambia solo la mappa aspetta quindi è un
ex club all con la mappa nuova per sé se
mi sa di sì c'è da quello che ho capito
mi sento e non si possono togliere le
uova delle altre
quello che è stato uomini giocano già un
gioco che già esiste ma modificato a me
fanno si può stare perché nuovo però
vabbè non si possono non si si possono
togliere ok difficile ma si possono
aiutarti a precari di far massa che la
porticina esatto è molto difficile
toglierle quindi se viene accaparri amo
il più possibile decisioni per noi e per
noi non ok allora mostare robe dentro è
molto più utile che portare fondata da
cuocere un uovo d'oro
fatelo schizzare a gago pio tagli tagli
e dai e andiamo sui nostri sui gialli
prossimi lei vieni che stanno cercate
prendere ho avuto la tele quello io ho
dentro di sabotare un po di gente
parlava e blu ho preso io per un istante
paesi dall'altra parte quando d'oro
crate poi di non va e dinho a quello di
far passare ma non passa non ho capito
poi dino vai dinho
lavoro si parlò abbiamo due uova dorate
spinge a joe ninja di merda spingi
aggiunto io per me riuscì avevamo 20
punti l'abbiamo 9 cosa è successo
scusate non lo so 29 che cosa vedi che
c'è una tattica per buttare fuori 64
ragazzino è stato già una tattica adesso
senti in tuffi a lato la botti bastato
farsi a lato adesso non va perché
c'erano quelli che manca pato però se
sei da solo non fatela passare alla
porticina tuffatevi a lato
basta quello qua c'è gente ferma ci sono
due giocatori fermi nei rossi quindi
immagino che i blu stiano giocando bene
visto che noi
maglie bravo l'a.d
la vuole questa scimmia questi qua non
hanno capito che se rimangono fermi a
grava aggrappare noi vergono perché non
fanno punti dal i gialli dobbiamo
togliere le gialli come che toccano
pianeta prima cosa che ho fatto ad essa
la tattica giusta ti tuffi e l'anci così
esce figo dai ci sta preferirei una
modalità nuova quindi non con le uova
altre robe
vabbè però almeno una mappa nuova per la
tattica quella che ventato però
quest'anno tanti così da raggiungere
fate lato sia certo non adatti carnet
coordinava bensì quella porticina non
passa nulla e papà infatti senza nome
assurdo però va bene questa uscita
sbagliando il derby ma al dunque la più
quella che mi lascia più curioso che
quelli del muro non è ancora uscita non
ho ben capito è infatti non ho ben
capito cosa hanno tolto cosa hanno tolto
hanno messo sono secondo me nulla nulla
più o meno tutto cos'è che non è mai
capitato ancora vorresti fare 24 mappe è
una rotation di 24 mappe e basta che
alcune lettini fuori che non è che le
butti via magari metti più avanti dicevo
guarda che hanno rimesso un jump l'epoca
era da molto che non c'è l'ha chiamato
andava veramente tanto in mano i giochi
acquisti
non so ragazzi nelle basi le basi e lui
perché non so videogiocatori non lo è
non lo so
milanetto ma cacchio non so ragazzi sono
di sap o internet no
ok io santa primo pure a livello di
marketing che ha ragione ma noi erano
gli torna ma centrano ritorna ovvio
perché tutti smettono ecco il problema
perché una volta ci ha abituato le nuove
mappe che non è manco messo in rotation
quindi the road e pure male forza occhio
la fai
decade 1 lega quindi noi già qualificato
ok creduto e che lo dirige
va bene
ancisi che rimaniamo vede un po di 18 ok
la gente si aspettava 15 size dunque lo
vedi sempre aveva 15 set 15 strano sta
quando c'è sembra che sia parato
se invece diamo tailleur nel finale per
lui da google
siamo in tre e privilegia me basta il
photoshop che di fatto perché cos'erano
fatto per nerf ma cosa di nerf che
esce tra un po perché mi mette quasi la
palla dall'altra parte su ball poi il
genere
io sono nato chieste spingono un sacco
qua più di voi che siete uomini forzuti
che sono uno dog non puoi immaginare e
spingi solo quando sei accesso verso
sinistra la sinistra è stata nessuna
intenzione stabilità adesso avete
spingete la casa sopra va bene non fa
niente onesto e si sono spezzate le
caviglie andate andate andata quando i
russi stata andata cross ma è stata
forte la palla
a los la tecnica qua ragazzi e spingere
subito come dico sempre non è mica bello
questo infatti non capisco una nemica
bello va bene abbiamo vinto
gigi quindi dovrebbe essere uscita non
squadre da quattro persone mi dovrebbe
essere in dieci ma mi sa che la juve non
vuole rischiare la pelle per un po a
premi una bella ciao ragazzi io dico
niente
non dico niente ragazzi perché hanno
giocato giochiamo da anch'io ci giocherò
ancora sto solo dicendo che se io fossi
a capo del game capo del game design di
sta roba vries cioè sarebbe il gioco più
giocato di ancora gli add on gaza sto
punto perché è evidente a dire dai ma ci
voleva tanto fare le migliori e poi è un
bel gioco sempre quello non c'è dubbio
però puoi fare una figata non la fai
vuoi mettere un freno si sa per quale
motivo questo quale venivano qua
ok perfetto perché io avevo letto che
palle l'ho visto che di turno
io sono risultate ieri da me stavo l'ha
già c'è nessuno maledetto basta solo io
questa giocata bene vogliamo mettere i
puntini sulle i ma giocata proprio bene
in realtà come ho fatto a cadere sono un
cretino raga era la cosa più facile non
cadere di son caduto non ci credo allora
isoliamo una porzione di mappa dove sei
io sono sul viola ma c'è gente che corre
maledetti ma no scusami
certo la strada scusatemi ragazzi è una
liberazione per di quello che volevo che
forse devo correre cosa scusate ma se
non ci passò il nostro molti altri
qualcosa si scusa scusa mi dovevo fare
sì perché sembravano hai fatto bene
tanto è prossimo che vede tutti treno sì
sì no no la gente che mi piove in faccia
no voglio certo c'è ancora uno so sopra
questo capita che io ho giocato
allora lo veramente ciò che a tale alle
migliorie delle mie possibilità quindi
non so quindi non potevo fare stavolta
quella volta veramente non sono neanche
caduto nel in punti strani l'ho giocata
al meglio di così non potevo fare il
ragazzino quindi gigi e va bene così una
volta non mi più male perché meglio di
così non potevo giocarla come si è detto
pure ma solo sbagliato prima volta però
ci sta anche noi
la forma finale mamma mia che è quello
da me per occupare pareti ei canoni di
così non si poteva fare
va bene così ma che avrebbe potuto
mettere qualche the coral ma neanche
cioè non vuoi tu dici puoi mettere le
decorazioni al 39 ok ma non è quello non
fa quello che va la nuova season quello
non faranno la season dove la cosa più
grave che non le mettono in rotazione
fisse penso che oggi è uscita non in
roma qua dicevano male ma le vecchie
cambiare qualcosina l'hanno fatto ma
quello non vuol dire niente legame che
il gioco
smetti di giocare forget perché ho
giocato un sacco di mappe sono sempre
uguali ha però abbiamo cambiato i colori
dei lollipop in disney mese climie fatto
ritorno a giocare ma cosa avviene senza
una niente non me ne frega niente
che hai cambiato e lollipop cmt
cambiavano che capiva il gioco si fa
stessa cosa
paura dicono le tre mappe su quattro
scivolare i muri che non ho capito bene
cos'e nato però non è ancora mai sci non
sono anche quando dovresti famosa
l'inizio
18 accade quando metti uno slang climb
qualcuno si è lamentato di stanno
pagando messo solo quattro mappe nuovo
no perché magari si lamentano cui
dischord loro ufficiale è un continuo in
su una condanna da un insulto continuano
a emergere facendo mio padre di colpi
lager e de il villaggio ride ma in
questa donna che craniata che ci ho
tirato ciò che posso fare questa parte
ti chiedo scusa non la posso fare
scusatemi e io che volevo giocare a
folgaria oggi
mannaggia di prenderla quando ok ecco
subito prenderla quando scende ok eva
tizi mammamia punti
in fondo devi correre di toro toro rosso
incredibile pensare che sono stata brava
a boss marina questa bella
secondo te dovrebbero togliere la cosa
di cadere appena ti avvicini di 2 mm e
un tuo avversario
abodi collision no dipende la devono
togliere a me per felice lo sono io
allora non la devono togliere perché
come dinamica ci sta così ti incavoli
anche con gli altri perché alla fine mi
incavolo però ci sta qui però non è
possibile che se lo faccio io gli altri
stanno in piedi quello sono cambiata
però avevo ormai ho perso la speranza
guardo più strana cosa hanno cambiato
dal partito per un piccolo riassunto per
tutti allora ogni volta che tiri un
pugno alla scrivania e windows gennaio
lega questo niente
ciao papi io mi chiamo fare comunque
potreste tutta l'america ricordo il
gioco horror magari da canon trasmesso
sia il mio nome che dicendo sì ci ha
fatto un casino
ciao bon jovi potresti salutare la mia
amica mi spaventa il gioco it farei
inter ragazzi friend boo addio a mosca
la tattica migliore per la parte pratica
si e buttarsi subito giù e fare bene la
discesa a buttarsi col salto sì però di
fare bene la dc no non scusami non amo
capitolo fenice
ok a parlare perché voglio dire tufo
come allora io ho visto uno raga adesso
non lo farò perché sono partito male che
però schipa va tutto a sinistra
se vuoi farlo io faccio sempre ciò
dipende come arrivi adesso per me
conviene farlo perché sono sono ero già
li vedi io sono già qua perché ero già
la sera invece che si apre al centro e
molto meglio andare al gene dipende come
arrivi se arrivi che ti si apre prima
sinistra a sinistra
fare una skin pazienza attivo e invece
no dai
ci sono pochi amici non mi qualifico leo
fuori no e niente e niente massima
infatti vic prima eravamo tutti o dog in
prima fila si vede che la vendetta degli
hot dog preso un martello né perché ce
ne sono tra l'altro io non riesco a
giocare ogni due secondi ma ragazzi
infatti dell'europeo
noi ci è andata bene adesso abbiamo
tenuto questo party funzionante e ci
mette sempre perché teoricamente già dei
problemi provate a riavviare proprio il
gioco vorrei finalmente attenta che
finalmente la puoi provare questa è leo
quanto è bravo taglia che poi ci sono
ottimi non è a tim
i primi 17 se qualifica capito ma quando
abbiamo funziona dobbiamo spingere ste
robe poi palesemente salirci sopra
dobbiamo spingere raga che in caso ci
salite sopra dovete spingerle non vuole
metterci i vicini sono c saliamo a noi
poi arrampicarvi tensione noi ci sarà
chi ti devi arrampicare passare prima da
oramai fatto a me il tasso dei tre è
promotore due allora devo trattare
questa per spostarlo che si spinge
sparino da nessuno non lo so no vabbè ha
fatto lo scoop del manico ma non va a
ragazzi non va no a motore così che
pirlo fai da te ma ma basta
oddio fatto una rona riferibile
perché ero da solo ok lavorati passata
davanti non ho neanche dati come tu
abbia fatto oddio ametista stilo quanto
fatto dei santi pazzeschi leonardo che
inneggiano un caro radicati a seguirti
eccoti di seiano e morto oggi sono
dimenticato di chi non salta quel
quadrato non lo fare come stai facendo
tu ce la farai mai più stato inquadrato
anche qua era stata male che ti ora che
poi gli utenti ma puntare direttamente
arrampicarti dalla brigata allora
ragazzi dovete spingere st piazzato e
non fanno fatto molto bravi bene di cosa
bravo bravo 9 si arrampicano di saltare
con quadrato si arriva v mi sa che io lo
odio ma childs interno ne manca uno
vabbè vabbè io non si arrampicano gara
c'era un tizio che sento sulla
piattaforma più alta senza quelle sotto
le all abisso
questa è la pista questa c lato proprio
ci stava anche nervoso che energia
questo ero primo era un primo questioni
accanto come questa va dei tre di fila
non è che abbiamo fatto tutte le nuove
caso io il problema si prende hanno
fatto tutte nuove
questa e lascia laurin un lemonia
targa l'unico la ricordi una
collaborazione hanno fatto tutto nuovo
quindi probabilmente quando abbiamo
detto che l'avete tenute ce l'hanno
messa in rotation e se i fatti hanno
fatto ci pensi che cazzo ma c'è la di
che si sta allettando facciamo un
attivata di non si può lamentare un paio
di quelli gialli non ho mai visto che
non sono seguite in lega pro seguite
colorata ricette lanciano in sé 2082
cioè un oro che lavoravamo devo
spostarmi che lo spostò grande fratello
ma perché così gentile primo da ma
valeva 5 è incredibile sì ma ha spostato
con lui
generoso
sa qual andrà tutto bene quindi come si
spostano questi con slay volere due
linee più moderne due è praticamente sì
così si gravano e si sposta intanto non
si sa chi sono i giganteschi che non è
possibile
il problema è che è proprio a me come
concetto questa roba qua mi piace anche
quelle quattro che hanno fatto secondo
me sono fatte pure bene ma fate le altre
c'è nel senso è proprio poi per fatto vi
girano sfrutta guidare dinamica madonna
è bellissimo è farne altre che proprio
vissuto
poi tra l'altro tra l'altro se io fossi
stato in vita mia avrei fatti proprio
diverse cioè questo è un sì daisy perché
l'hanno cambiato e l'altro ex crumble
cambiato quindi creare le nuove cose
ceco però bad che non c'entra nulla con
le uova con centro una grigia che in
altra roba
va bene anche così però di quella
proprio diverse blue the wall il muro è
il poker è arrivati a quella è
completamente roma fate tutte le le fate
tutte così anche queste non sono male
però siccome ne hai fatte quattro se ne
fai complementari le falle cioè se ne fa
in 12 quindi ne fai tante ne fai alcune
simile dalle altri books iniziando le
fai te ne fai 4 oppure fai tutte no
almeno almeno quello comunque non è che
non sono pronto a me piace questa mi
piacciono tutte quanto in realtà non
sono male però porca vacca finale nuovo
però l'abbiamo fatto tutti e quattro i
non può essere magari scampo meno male
che meno male che poi il monte perché
non vedevano raffigura dietro quarto
dietro forse l'avanti sai forse forse
forse sono con in alto a destra tensione
[Musica]
scrivente ragazzi spero mi sia piaciuta
anche questa
guarda che tanto anche un pirla perché
si è fermato le braccia russia e non
sono partito comunque secondo quindi un
casqué la posso vincere però ci credo lo
stesso
vabbè non facciamo facciamo va bene
l'articolo lì lo vede in difficoltà
[Risate]
grandi ma è bellissimo vederlo della
visione speed dating perché
completamente noi è successo
non so bene quale sarà in piedi ecco i
piedi no tanto non si poteva vincere
comunque almeno giocava bene mannaggia
al cacchio massimo grazie alla donazione
caro dyer agani chiama vittoria oggi che
basta che non esca basta che non è col
montegiorgio chiamo però non deve uscito
al mondo taglierà sarà la gonna ragazzi
non so se la gode non lo so let's go on
ice wine pablos la connected drive cielo
sarà web grazie mille falso il blu
grazie mi legano comunque questa era
piena di robe nuove magari capita che
finiamo alle 8 perché una fame
incredibile sono le sei e venti centri
maggiori il tavolo adesso
tagli poi c'è già miss usa è sarebbe
anche da giocare jobso dow spero che
quella sì anche se ultimamente jam
showdown la gente è diventata molto più
forte ti ritrovi nelle ultime due
piattaforme con 67 persone ed è un tour
a 10 minuti
infatti come è successo prima stef poi
io gravi o muori
e chi sono ma donation caro ove l'isis o
avevo detto ma che proprio non c'è mai
cambiata si sono formato io non ci danno
di cannoni adesso guarda alla foto era
diversa dalla foto ciao nei cannoni
sotto ce l'avessero massi cannoni e di
turisti jobs in modalità dalla foto è
divertito anche una sua foto caricando e
adesso adesso no sto sempre su niente mi
pagarono adesso ci stiamo a riguardo
finale dove sei
sempre se fa foto mamma mia che palle
mamma mia
dopo che queste scarpe che ti avevo
comprato erano molto più prestanti ieri
ho fatto una prova madonna infatti nella
merita questa caduta totale una cagata
perché ho visto mila che era tutto vuoto
ma non aveva senso che se quella roba lì
e hanno messo la direzione ma forse c'è
la prima grazie pensione modo parte
nessuno questa piattaforma
ok ma come mai come mai come mai questo
è abbiamo solo sfiga qua e là ma tu sei
amante poco siamo dati è sbagliato
sbagliatissimo proprio tutto ok ci devo
provare taglierà year
dividiamoci ragazze ci dividiamo la
piattaforma renato ma va giù tutta c'è
uno sopra ma c'era uno sopra quanto vuoi
che qualche pezzo vuoi che faccia una
persona niente perché quello sopra è
probabilmente l'unica persona
intelligente ma veramente c'era un
pallone bayern e no questa crolla questa
crolla regalando ad esso opera reagan
date sopra ma andatevene a ce ne sono
solo due dietro simile apposta dei
tira significato no semmai now per
ottenuta tantissimo vita e madonna lei
pieri gente ma che è
ciao bayern
non ci salti sì cosa ci mercantile della
piattaforma lì no no anche stampa di non
seguire gli amici sua fan è niente di
mannaggia
oggi non è giornata dal mei folk aisla
che non so chi cazzo è ma non riesco a
fare nulla no no no no no no ok va bene
questa comunque siamo arrivati molti in
molti di meno al traguardo invece il
party bus tram nuova mappa nuova manovra
ma non ho mai a boss e cicaglia che la
skin maledetta dog padova cambio infatti
cambiano c'è orribile sa parli tu che
c'è la duchessa ovviamente no no no no
la mia parola o male nulla niente file i
porti sul canale consob sushi ma mi sa
che allora sa che
no però perché no perché mi sa che c'è
mi sa che c'è tutto registrato dalle
line non ti trovo la di sono quello che
accade infatti infatti tavolo
selezionato per il momento in cui sta
scivolando mamma mia leo è nato per fare
questo ma leo non c'è ma io non ci sto e
allora perché votano lega no flashato io
praticamente quando tu speck ti gli
altri in basso si sa c'è il tag cioè la
cosa e io pensavo che quelli arancioni
fosse rito e compagni che cadevano dante
tirava arancione e il col saint io ti
prego che intel abbia fatto un salto che
madonna
mai fatto a cambiare la targhetta eccolo
altro come hai fatto atterrare in piedi
in una parete verticale questa è la
prova che non lo so poi sono furti guai
hanno fatto primo qua veramente
importante era che si infatti nella
nuova modalità ma poi ce la fai ancora
in tempo se si alza al ponte a tuffarti
se non è completamente alzato un salto
di qualità esatto brian ho fatto un
salto di qualità non ragazzi questa la
vincere basta di queste tua
questo anche perché io sono stato
eliminato e quindi quando io sono
eliminato vuol dire che nessuno al
diritto di vincere adesso esatto nessuna
parte
questo mi sa che non volevo però leo era
un po basta guardare l'immagine di
deciso era una donna parlando limitati
male lei non siamo stati sul canale
allora le live francesca rimangono per
gli abbonati sono tranne quelle
pomeridiane che rimangono pubbliche
perché la life americana sostituisce il
video del giorno quindi se non ci fosse
pubblici sono forse pubblica non ci
sarebbe bisogno del giorno mi calai il
pomeridiana quindi questa rimane salvata
ma le altre che facciamo in settimana
nera per gli abbonati
yes vittoria
vediamo come non hanno fissato le cose
che non hanno fissato le cose
effettivamente le cose ragazzi quello
che dico che gli altri ma prendono da un
chilometro e che io non la prendo mai
agli altri se non ci sono di girato poi
sentendo come fix per cui avendo un bel
viola acceso
sono meno code e adesso attenzione
abbiamo tre per squadra e me la prendo
per forza mantenendo entra tolta questa
diviene il babbo forse hanno spiccato
finalmente poche cose adesso sì ero
hanno proprio fissato per fanno
veramente chissà come mai io adesso sì
che abbiamo risolto si hanno aumentato
il wifi che sorprenderà più lontano beh
sa che voleva coraggio che se poi questi
questi giga di pensione hanno potenziato
il segnale per cento però ti devi
muovere zio ma possiamo avere uno ma
veramente ma quanto quanto può essere
stuprata ci trovano tipi ma l'hai visto
se sia il papà io veramente non so cosa
dire ho fatto rubata e te lo dico io
come ha fatto non basta no non me lo
dire che andavano meglio così allora
come lo di verona non te lo dico di no
peccato perché te lo volevo proprio dire
quando invece chi l'ha beccata meno la
presa qua è perché secondo me hai mai
vabbè dai gigi prossima volta
va bene e poi doni anche se forse stai
più vicino attaccato da non laurea
esatto avranno fatto bene a togliere una
cosa perché è un casino prima erano 5
per cento
sì ci siano 5 adesso ce ne sono quattro
per team
mi sa di no scusa tre no perché esami
con i 30 e per di perché il totale non
siete la crisi un po più chi ha la coda
è più è molto più rari molto grave la
coda ma perché già club oggi ma che
c'hanno con jam club perché mi dà un
fastidio quando perdo pare mimì rondon
l'appunto un papero la riva attenzione
ma per ogni editore la tua testa che si
spezza ogni volta che ti passa le cose
rosa sopra va bene a leo razzo ma con in
da giacomo caro grazie grazie blood e
veniamo insistenza e non avendo sta cosa
come la vedi no nella telecamera vedo
che il cappellino ci tocca al cosa rose
di si spezza il collo proprio il segnale
come si chiama il simbolo di quando i t
qualcosa in marian witmark esatto stato
dato tensione
si aprì o perché non si può fare
napolitano sempre giovane ambiente
davanti a casa mia c'è una fattura così
come è volato tra l'altro malissimo da
casa mia c'è una fattoria io quando vado
lì tra i padri migravano relativa all
antica gradi ma lei sa che dicono a lei
sa bene chi sia in ostaggio di due
paperi a boss finisce la partita
dobbiamo tirare così anche grazie io vi
popolare per questo mi sono permesso
dirlo allora per e io lo so fare la lega
sa fare
[Risate]
eccolo abbiamo cominciato un caro 12
finale vero mattatore di paperissima
neanche il motore quello che piazza i
suoni capito sono 19 i suoni incredibili
che usa gli stessi avversata da 85 sini
punto mp3 just be baraonda pensa che io
lo sapevo anche tutta memoria condannati
piacimento acb è una cifra è brillante
il maestro cose che fanno ti fanno
diventare uomo fatto diventare matto non
verdini allagati allagati giuro che mi
ha scattato non ho capito niente nel
momento in cui non doveva scattare bravo
però come ti sei tenuto mi ha scattato
lo schema non ho visto niente
però però vedi che c'è qualcosa di
strano perché rimangono lui rimangono
tre rimangono poche piattaforme
discostate l'una dell'altra e strana sta
cosa cioè non rimanevano così cioè che
la gente ad una bici si stia giocando a
cava che strano certo per caso stanno
gioca a caso si giovano a caso scendono
cadono corrono
perché se tutti sapevano che cacchio ti
corri brutto idiota mammamia latte ma
perché c'era quello che correvano in
preso male non dedico questa pratica una
piattaforma cattiva e la piattaforma che
rimane a lei ora questo che mi corrado
guarda guarda ma perché c'è la crisi ma
che cosa c'è light e nel cervello ma non
correte correte a fare questa questo è
molto buona e brother uno ne rimane uno
doveva come messo e non lo vedo penso
che sia sopra però se non la vedo quali
abbado piano e carola ok caduto
l'attenzione non ne venivano la scopa ma
volendo anche le piattaforme pervenire
la terna senso se sa giocare bene
no vabbè no una cosa però che sfiga
brother adesso se posso permettermi
posso farlo e dico svenuto visto a
teatro una spallata negli organi di
professare una fascia di vedere a
valenti perché vi faccio vedere il
problema visto gioco
ricky bel grazie sei una tripla the
nation
perché guarda guarda guarda guarda che
guarda che cosa è successo e guarda
guarda guarda
visto lui arriva lui arriva dal niente
mi spinge io rag doll oper tella e
perderà questa cosa se io fossi stato in
lui a lui non succedeva cioè se io mi
butto su qualcuno poi qualcuno non cade
lui ha vinto una partita perché lui può
fare una cosa che io agli altri non
posso fare questa questo è sbagliato è
vero che le desse a breve se adesso
partiamo una partita iniziava all'inizio
mi butto su di te di miseria gol etoo
non brandoli perché io non ho questa
cosa non la posso fare di lui ha vinto
perché può fare una cosa che io non
posso fare quindi si è fatto una
scivolata alla cannavaro e sei volato
che cosa mi devo dire ragazzi ho vinto
una corona mantenete ve la fate a cagare
[Risate]
dlf debito non erano tesi a partita
uscì uscite manica l'euro ma devi uscire
che manca leo che 9 allora si torna
dritta e time legno i ragazzi cosa mi
devo dire niente andò questa se per se
prese permettete mela conto come non
l'ha contoli non avete neanche nel
counter
ma per me questa è vinta cioè non vale
soprattutto veramente se posso
permettere le altre si fa questa no qua
io non è non può non posso valere meno
degli altri
adesso io mi butto su di voi vi faccio
non avete non avete idea di quanto sto
problema ma no ma direi che poi in
realtà non sto realizzando mi anzi per
me è un godimento farvi vedere quanto è
fatto da schifo almeno almeno almeno non
parlo da solo
almeno fare una seria io adesso vengo
tutto no io no perché almeno fa vi
faccio vedere quanto questo gioco fa io
adesso mila partiamo mi lancio su un
player e guardate come quel player non
cade
faccio la stessa cosa faccio la stessa
cosa ma quella al traguardo quando
andiamo coi primi ragazzi che deve
scambiare di cambiare la skin adesso mi
lancio
palermo adesso mi lancio su un player e
vediamo il contatore 341 ragazzi non
l'ho messo perché se avessi sono due ma
fa niente
qual è allora no no no no sono sicuro
che non cada perché non è mai caduto
fino ad ora quindi non so mi hanno o
hanno fissato ma non penso a meno che
non abbiano fissato dalla famosissima
fino qua non mi butto su nichi mi butto
su quello che prendo la madonna come era
come a razzo lato non so come farà
rialzarsi come fare la nuova guarda
poverino maris non ha staccato il
joystick raccagna areva gioco maledetto
non hanno usato per italo fa ho fatto
non ho fatto la stessa cosa che mi ha
fatto lui o ragazzi avete appena visto e
poi uno che sai cos'è che seguono le
dice se quando dici ai tuoi amici i no
ma non è giusto perché a me questa cosa
non funziona che talevi intendevi
giustifica c'è la babysitter o ce
l'avete in video l'ho fatta in video e
niente ingerita di merda da ex pro pausa
estiva
ci siamo poi smetterla lei è un hobby
sono sputato target però cambia la skin
è vero anche che le crode allora qual è
netto e non è che ne ho di bellissima
dire la verità allora facemmo tipo così
effetto sei molto bene grazie
ok facciamo una bella combo la duchessa
è quella cosa lì che ho io
io veramente non so per quello dico e se
avessi perso da solo avrei tirato una
testata al monitor ma almeno ce l'avete
in live e questa cosa mi fa un po godere
del fatto di potervi far vedere quanto è
fatto da sé perché non l'avete in video
quindi sono apposta
tu eri per te ero per terra ma vatti a
rivedere il pezzo ma vabbè
ferraro stava saltando come è stato lui
a schemi mette già in prima posizione il
tuo unicorno la dirigono in chat
se il mio unico a me va bene giuseppe lo
conte giacomo ragastas al massimo più
che per terra stava saltando ragazzi ma
saltando a me cioè a me puntato anche se
non salto e purtroppo perché mi conosce
ci sono minimi b si è buttato su anche
se non salto caso quello potrebbe essere
però non vuol dire niente uguale perché
mi succede anche se non salto quindi ero
per terra mamma mia
poi era un ex ha convinta ai ragazzi
semplicemente non me l'hanno fatto
quella non è che sono vinta dichiarata
se ti colpisce in volo non cambia niente
cioè cadeau uguale sia che mi colpisca
il ruolo che mi sa che mi colpisca per
terra e quello che cambia è quello che
capisco io io cioè se guardate i
migliori fotocamere sapete che il mio
personaggio rag doll al triplo a causa
poi ci sono sì bambini vale pm perché di
arrivare per terzo è visto si è fermato
a me ha sentito come siete messi l'a.d
io sono molto avanti io sono arrivato
leo ai ragazzi non c'è stato ma io so
perché ha capito io lo so la forza di
volontà alzate le mani al cielo per led
per le ragazze con tutti con te dai che
ci sei mai successo pure tu cose qua che
sto zitto proprio perché è molto tra
stato e non lo siamo
questo può comunque la skin più brutta
della mia se il gatto con i boxer a
cuoricini rosa è veramente forse più
brutta della mia adesso non unicorno
colto tutti certo è difficile da battere
bella mossa ok manovra che era mancato
anche prima che con l'aggiornamento è
successo sta roba da quando sceglie la
quando c'è folk ice che succede quindi
non è l'aggiornamento avrebbero dovuto
fissarlo sarebbe stato interessante ma
come va bene grazie vale lo sapevo di
poter contare su di voi
ma sì ragazzi cioè va bene basta che vi
togliamo vediamo che manca un'ora e
mezza dai andiamo percepito in peggio
andiamo peggio in peggio a una nuova
mela fate giocare che gli sviluppatori
una e mail domandare sviluppata di
perché ce ne vorrei giocare
ecco la perfetta ottava crollare io ero
in voterà anche il gioco tra un po non
era mai capitata dopo questa no questa è
no questo mai
oggi no questo è il dubbio capolavori e
invece hanno messo mantello alla fine
che non lo vedo no non mi pare di
vederlo perché continuare in ballo ha
detto ciò in un occhio sì c'è il
martello ragazzo se un aquila dove non
c'è il martello non sono e palla che
cadono bene aquila un po così dai devi
togliere ci devi togliere anche tra
ok questa come volato malissimo coraggio
ei nicolosi stimo ma perché è in una
buona posizione
ai miei ex fatto.il arriviamo pure
assieme guadagni che campione mamma non
jazz comunque sbaglio più difficile
questa gente più brava
non ho capito perché allora di tele
times allora mi sembrano tutti i più
trogloditi nel solito però che stanno a
pochi istituti spediti tutti i corridori
asciugamani dai camon che erano eros
thrier davano abbastanza duro
diamo bloc party roll out
niente anche perché non tutti al canale
che mancato pochissimo ai 6 milioni
manca veramente poca roba appena ci
siamo facciamo un menù per parti quindi
due primari ma descrivendo i vostri
amici di dell'air france che qua
travolto importante mammamia latte mi
sembra ieri te lo giuro ma min
la mia schiena ed ascom teca però
segnala scooter ayers cagliari che
abbiamo inizia cosi la prendo io sto
alzati però sono nato come logo che mi
sento abbiamo picchiandoli de leo il
fascio di star ottenuto veronica nel
lanciare l'uomo con tutti i lanci e lo
lasci la sua ormai prima non si poteva
far martic adesso si poteva fare non
l'ho mai fatto non l'ho mai fatto i
premi hicks quadrato e ti lancia luoghi
codrignano anche se premi xe basta e lo
lasci mentre stai saltare lo sa bene
ok i gialli gialli sono tutti
contenimento se mi fate passare la gag
radio si è mai visto niente
posso giocare nudità ma cazzo
io rido perché mi immagino a faccia tra
i pesi e bellissima bayern derivato uno
prende culo lanciarazzi abroad
ovviamente la musichetta qua nuova
l'ultimo no io cosa vuoi rosso maledetto
6 nuove gialli questa una partita
unilaterale
io difendo perché non hanno detto niente
per riuscire a senso unico vuol dire
dire questo è giusto unidirezionale
anche va bene mi va benissimo
arriviamo al 50 punti prima punta certo
ci ha rubato un futuro
luciano avuto qua bene che non ci
arrabbiamo torino che bravo il blu
rappreso luogo è bravo è schizzato un
nuovo in webcam cioè non so come sia
possibile taglia
a cavallo ci siano non va bene a cavallo
il cavallo si è andato a preparare rossi
anzi sta nel spam
oggi però dice ma sto punto potevano
rimuovere queste mappa e lasciare quella
della nuova season del multivan
bonissimo capito niente poteva dire che
scrumble lasciare quello nuovo è un po
tutti discorsi che abbiamo fatto che se
ci siano arrivati come abbiamo fatto nei
discorsi dove che la era la bara uno più
uno uguale 2 e non ci sono arrivati a fa
quello sì resi l'hanno fatto perché non
c'è quella vecchia
è vero come siano magari e non e non
abbiamo semplicemente vista proprio
lunedì hanno fatto qui sono d'accordo
anch'io che cacchio metti ii x3 rumble
come infatti secondo me i ragazzi nella
partita circa un paio di nove un paio di
robe ele cambieranno c'è adesso vada
cambiato tipo domani
c'era una scatola era neanche aspettano
un giorno perché mi farebbe ridere
oddio raga non provate mai a tuffarvi
sopra la cosa verde mai sono tuffato
posso subito appena lei né quinto tuffo
ma quel quadrato proprio no no no no no
no non ti prego rialzati la gente
moltissimo ho sentito il patto o non
anni ama dei remake secondo e così è
tutto bene ecco da quello che invece
rimane lì per sempre è salvato ma
nessuno si gioca al cavallo è caduto il
cavallo è caduto a gallo ei
attore bubbles abbiamo visto rotolare
giù come non so che l'ex crumble dunque
il campo mette a dura prova questo gioco
i ragazzi la voglia di capire quanto un
bel film all
oppure in finale in extra come speriamo
non fa il mondo non è uscito fracture
anche tra le altre è vero più 58 meno
male che c'è di peggio e tipo perfect
match
eccolo casta ma fantinel schifo poi dato
sempre uguale ho cambiato niente
veramente no sente che non lo mangia tal
anguria per quello che sono
siamo in seconda fila
siamo primi se siamo primi ma pure che
abbado che vita triste ai avverso è lui
è tempo di 220 mi fa mai caduta mente se
parti secondo per appare tanto non puoi
non puoi vincere quindi effettivamente
per nominare gli altri ci potrebbe stare
se sei secondo dietro al primo prima
visione anche lui
va bene stai facendo mentre stai andando
però ad ora stai facendo
no no no no no no no no ma se devo fare
impresa prima il bellissimo perché se
spuntava una corona a casa e un easter
egg di formante ingresso nella casa per
guardare su scherzi ma sai che stai sul
tour pensa guarda l'hai detto per
scherzo e sarebbe già una cosa
incredibile rendere all'atomica formont
e tanto voglio dire alla prima c'era
qualsiasi fase di giri di la sinistra e
quali la tua mensola trovi 10 mini
giochi milioni preciso aspetta prova
chauffeur night sulla sinistra scherzo
erano ragazzi siamo scarsi scherza
ironia jolo dai oggi dobbiamo vincere
una lega che ancora non ho una famiglia
di mangiare il tavolo però non lo merito
solo sarà vinciamo belle le musichette
nuove comunque
è giunto il tuo quali livelli hanno
tolto hanno tolto nessuno tranne
friction non c'è mai capitato che
diciamo che non ci è capitato però non
so se sia più giusto non ci sono
capitate però non lo sappiamo in realtà
quando mi suona tex legend ha tentato un
cavallo in camera brodo ma i giochi non
mi grappa re non mi gran pare ben erboso
che pescava arrivare da che in finale
tra un po sbagliato porta peccavano
cantoni si sono tuffati addosso ragazzi
mi devo preoccupare
poi c'è una segnalazione di server io
dico mai saperlo per il culo la porta
quali sta palesemente perduto il culo
si si si si si era presa da mi sta
crollando
ora che gli ho perso perché le porte mi
frullavano perché mi ci apriva una porta
aspetta aspetta
ok
mamma mia che ansia di quel che ad un
certo punto verso la terza schiera di
porte ce n'è una che non si apre mai
si no quella lì si era non so è l'unica
volta che l'ho beccata che si apriva
normalmente come le altre
allora ho visto tutti i cretini in fila
dietro quello che trova bene vado sulle
altre a me mi sono da real e non si
chiedevano più allora detto vabbè
ritorno su quella basano su e lapam si è
alzata quelle non si chiuderà il fiume
dalle altre detto va bene allora lesto e
via comunque
vedo da letta ci sono tutte le mappe
anche freak shoot è anche utile sì
perché le vedo mentre c'è l'ex tappe
adesso che sono passate tutte sono
autori che non è capitato ancora c'è una
costante o la nota rotation ma non di
base non le hanno tolto perché ci sono
nelle varie cose va bene allora mi devi
ok non mi stava prendendo il joystick
il savona non mi gravare cavallo di
merda che cominciamo già male la nostra
relazione poi cavallo pago un ma magari
caschi ma magari curtis ma magari casi
magari casi le castella segnale
nell'ambiente
la mossa quello che s'è salvata ma
quanto per giorno e nicolò ma magari i
caschi avevate non mi toccate vice ivano
giulia grazie ma donation cara autori la
mia stima effettivamente non non vedo
perché non bisogna si possa durare dai
raga ne mancano due mi stanno gravando
ne manca uno bozzi territorio mamma mia
come mi sono salvato prima ancora non
taglierà gli ar agli 11 lega 1 prego ho
rischiato di essere io quello tantissimo
quell 1 che cadeva siamo tutti ragazzi
ufficio alle caso non si fosse mai ho
più bisogno fisico di mutarli bellissimo
detto esattamente disperazione risate
isteriche se avesse avuto quello che gli
ha fatto arrivata nella casa la salutava
sempre ragazzo breve terremoto con il
vice la cavi manager ragazzo di della
ragazza di roma che ha urlato dalle
cesana buffon cesa www
[Risate]
lo prendo io i veniano peccato perché
adesso ci servi tantissimo perché ci
saranno sti maledetti al posto tuo che
non sanno vale da solo ho preso luogo
pomodoro
ma c'è un figlio vado dritto e quando
esco da lì ma ce la fate ad arrivarmi
addosso
va tutto bene come faccio e successo
come faccio io vi fermate ma che cacchio
perdete le uova sarà tanto se qui mi
sento mai scusa se ho fatto niente
il papero guarda guarda ai gialli
ok tanto per cambiare oggi questo senso
di meritarla
vabbè c'è un giallo fermo da noi perché
sta puntando lunedì già all'attenzione
c'è il nuovo giallo portate via roma con
date di roma di via roma
dicono lancio io lei che lo lancia così
alla fine prese tube mix inquadrato
lanciano più giocato fuori questa manina
peak quadrato ok vedi bello è che ha
portate l'ho detto no il blu il blu e
ritirando fuori un miliardo lega non
vado neanche l'ultima piattaforma vengo
quali punto fuori lottato racchiusa una
macchinetta proprio sì ci abbiamo noi
non tutte veramente un miliardo
ovviamente io ho fatto i pallini gialli
mamma mia o dei che culo il martello non
tirati fuori un miliardo e mezzo
i blu che rischiano ma guarda se il blu
non sono i mirati e solo perché ho fatto
una strage tirati fuori aver tagliato
fuori 20 uova tuo nome e gigi dai che
tanto questo non è certo
sono tre le gare si siete 10 secondi
questo proprio io bravo quindi in mano
ma ora ce l'ha fatto questa comunità
astro erano meglio i gialli libro meglio
sabotati in modo finale è un bene che
siano rimasti gialli perché sono i più
scarsini quindi
però comunque adesso sto vedendo come
togliere le uova seriamente prendi in
considerazione del fatto che aprire una
ditta di traslochi a chi si prende in
considerazione senza dubbio tutti i
popoli che gli annunci che trovi nel dei
pali ogni tanto dalla città sappiamo
cantine ai laghi detto sento che ti
invito a casa per mangiare un po di
ancora ci mancherebbe anzi dentro il
frigo assicurati contrario di in
compagnia ragazzi che non mangiano
angola in compagnia niente
non posso continuare c'è la coda è
oramai pensa che ti stanno già puntando
cambiato direzione tantissimo ok cosa
cosa sente e non presa storia è compresa
merita l'avrebbero presa infatti ma non
sa che il joystick sta dando sta dando
problemi compreso pulini la rocket
destato le primarie che tranvia
prendiamo mi sono visto perché ti
avrebbero rubata mai fatto bene senti
veramente fermata un puntato allora non
funziona è ok e questo spettacolo così
funziona è stato anche ci ha premuto r2
quando si si non mi ha fatto immaginato
sordi fallo no no caduto un po di lavoro
occhio ai ragazzi che abbiamo la cosa
dobbiamo farci lecciso mele serio nel
file come le sardine capito dobbiamo
muoverci come un branco unico
banco anziché che comunque sardina
niente di nuovo il cazzeggio no no no no
latino trovato tali da rubato da rubato
ma cos'è che succede a sentirci però che
il joystick
ma guarda che va bene per me è vero
anche uno di loro ma lui perché la nato
non hai ora proprio che mi si spegne il
joystick regate con tutto me stesso
anche una parte di qualcun altro che
quello blu affanculo sarà in uscita
siamo usciti
where's the family friendly ex.it rytas
di testa che odio micia lati splash che
baraonda ma va bene che non mi stavi a
guardare ma non ho visti si spegneva
agonistica impossibile da vincere di
nuovo mi si è spento ma che succede però
ci sono ancora problemi nati o
finalmente una mappa che dove posso
sperare di vincere se mi mette il pezzo
di f io veramente vorrei posare il
joystick per protesta ma non lo farò
solo ed esclusivamente perché possa
avervi incontrato magari dei giocatori
babbi che magari fino alla fine non ci
arrivano
cosa molto difficile che non mi è mai
successa ma vabbè però io per joyce per
per protestare a mollare il joystick per
joystick mollerei protetti la protesta
allora io provo a cambiare capo del
joystick perché tanto non non si può
porca vacca ma posso partire primo una
volta una che porterebbe poi parte il
fatto che prendi se prendi sei parti poi
per secondo inning
sbagliati e quindi ci metti pure più il
tempo ad arrivare appena neanche 10
massimo inutile inutile c'era il cavo le
gare già abile a jean vigo e sfortuna
cioè in un ci credo giusto in tilt anche
giusto una delle modalità dove non puoi
stare fermo
peccato era nato anche bene le altre ma
per niente continua uscire col monte in
finché continua cile formante vaffan
correva un secondo momento sembrano pure
napoletana
basta vi prego ok adesso lo che ho
sentito ancora sentita come guarda si
sono nella l'immagine guarda come
diversa davvero ci sono i cannoni ma
cercano ma guarda l'immagine
ma secondo me allora qualche volta potrà
anche sparare così cioè potrebbe anche
se invece li toccava sull'immagine no
vabbè ma che spiega meglio all'inizio
magari abbinati a un fiore è un sostegno
sul sito solo tu sì solo quando c'è una
serie che va bene
fra i beni che adesso ma sbloccato quasi
l'orco mi manca una partita e sblocco
l'orco shane mail per cortesia tre
corone losche lì che bello tutto come lo
schifo bello che comunque ti fa comprare
le celebration ma non te le fa vedere
c'è veramente le basi più bancario di
prima il più pacato di prima che sulla
celebre show non li faceva vedere invece
pure prima io mi sono messo a vederla è
la celebration e fa vedere solo se le
prendi la season pass 3 comprino
fidatevi novello la natura di sei uscito
è per forza non sono uscite non sono
stanco mi merito ha dentro la partita
non sono allora aspetta che esco mi sono
qualificato io giusto così per farmi
uscire mi si è bloccato di nuovo il
joystick
intanto evitando l'orco a me non piacerà
america i tori più che ingente quando
facciamo il team esce ai libri mai i dub
rock
evo il joystick ma secondo me ha qualche
problema con la compatibilità con il
joystick sai a me non è un problema che
non no no no cacciata perché non ha
fatto anche su rocket league prima
quindi no per capirti perchè incollaggio
lamentano hanno ridotto la potenza alla
capacità di giocare col jens lehmann po
più che altro 6 magari qualche crash e
incredibile tipo cod non l'hanno
aggiornato 65 giga di aggiornamento lo
aviti crasha durante la partita random
così va bene fanno peggio quando peggio
e si è un cambiamento non è ancora come
si suol dire male si son due molto male
vedi tocca parla male di matera e mezza
che mai risulta nel gioco metrica
diciamo che alla fine palese speriamo
non ti faccio vedere solo la foto però o
non ricadano partito pro gay
speriamo camera così sennò è si è
limitato a prescindere pesce sì sostengo
il gioco altezze 42
daje regà ha mosso bene bene bene io
questa voglio provare a mascherarlo col
timer che non sono male in questa quando
ho detto al caso
no non spingete però dio e il bene di
quello che vedi quello che vi dico
quando avevo saltato è qua non avevo
saltato non avevo fatto niente ma se mi
hanno spinto male denti what he
collision in teoria se cose sono
studiate per andrebbe protetto cioè se
tu vai dritto dritto per dritto proprio
riesci a a passare i sì secondo me li
guardo e non mi spingere ha dovuto al
contrario ben tre ste cose sono più
difficili da vedere perché non ti muovi
no manca miseria nel buchino del cavolo
che c'è lì dove da sempre uno stesso
book o mi seguono mi seguono
ecco le ha mosso bene vai vai su cosa
sinistra no a destra a destra fino a te
quali quello di gpg o comunque ho capito
come si fa
ho capito come si fa cit quale qual è
questa qua questa mappa qua io ho
bisogno di riprendere bene il tempo è
solo questioni prende bene il tempo è di
tempo ho visto quello o comunque sti
buchi nella mappa lison geniali cioè
veramente quelle che hanno fatto non
fatte bene veramente stronzi per me lo
voglio fare di più
sappiamo di facciate spero che
continuino a fare tutte quelle nuove
hamelin staranno al muro e loro no ecco
un anomalo che vanta la carica più
vediamo carica meno male però era bull
sarà pagato fermato hanno raggiunto ma
che basta a bello questo aggiornamento
cosa c'è bug
ok richiamo lo ha confermato i bug
nasco panatta le banche e poi pasta e
fagioli ma sai bug pasta e vagoni brutto
bancarotta basta potremmo continuare
così per ora i ragazzi io ve lo dico
perché al mondo bancario culturale di
niente tagli e piattaforma no regala
pregato veterana dall'altra parte regalo
bellissimo è riuscito il punk pop di jan
viene bellissima poi questo personaggio
di preferito ragazzi di new york era con
loro parlo più non parlo più bassa
bastava sala sata io pensando non
mancano ma veranda pagherà pagherà del
libro della giungla cosa sto vedendo
cannati mago perché regala tutti a testa
è tutta la quale stavano viaggiando
nell'aria questo mago scusate
no no no non mi fa dopo l'era leo sulla
penultima sulla fine che se mai ce la
puoi fare ha detto adesso ha destato
subito si sta qua non fate tuffate non
sviluppi mai perché se non cade più
facile occhio luzzati mutati vai vai vai
mai mettere montati sui miei livelli
ad essere particolato adesso no ecco non
sono però mai invece immutati mutati
pero vai a sinistra si è votato molti ma
chi è questo che consiglia neanche in è
che come giocare così e mutati
non c'è più le hole and also una
finestra che arriva da roma tende
collegio va avere conosciuto in
esercizio spirituale
questo è un esercizio spirituale beh
avete che dicevamo che l'hanno tolta
invece ci piaceva così tanto a tutti
quanti
la lega applicate che non arrivino le
angurie in testa minacciandoli season 2
in questo patto di aggiornamento è la
risposta è no
eccolo è fatto non è neanche non no
purtroppo no non c'è niente
un caduto sulla culla addio iscriverò lo
sfilata su come questa no però è
arrivata in faccia potente dagli esali
trasmettete director armi addosso magari
no l'anguria no ma sempre magari una
maledizione
la maledizione della prima ancora dagli
ok tanti tanti arrivati primo rigori
così mamma mia 17 18 è veramente in culo
dove mamma mia jason cascata una volta
alla fine hanno capito cosa è successo
lavorava
di chi comunque non sono né ancora che
vengono date sei tu che vai da loro non
ne puoi fare a me certo si guarda di una
volta lo sulla piattaforma e me ne è
arrivata una in testa non ero neanche
sceso nel tapis roulant sotto quindi
figurati le loro uova strapazzate extra
mo ci sei gay e solitario bilancio
subito su quelli d'oro e fra ora come
bilancio come un professionista ho preso
hanno preso non l'ho preso come con e su
ciò che veramente tanti e si paga ma vi
costa tanto spingerli sotto cioè nel
senso
avola dire di arrivato anche uno d'oro
scusate ma volevo farlo
va bene gialli dalle è un nuovo toro
lega aveva preso ho preso non sai che lo
vediamo saloon neuroni rossi avesse non
andrebbero subito contro i gialli perché
sono gli unici
vediamo però sono tutti la loro allora
che ha posto e stanno tutti la mia
montino capitano li devo andare subito
in debole perché deve perdere di chi con
l'uovo d'oro e se sto qua adesso lui con
cattiveria non volevo abbracciare tema
si qua anche i gialli non sono più
svegli perché dovevo andare tutti una
bella battellata super mi preme che io
l'ho presa io qual è una lista mente del
mcdonald's è vero per drive si
tournament rai torna al mcdrive lasciano
quasi niente non mi va bene cosa di
gianni come sovrappreso sto male da
gianni brera allettato hai visto come lo
depistato però dove sto perdendo
rantolare per un chilometro
non so se si è rialzato e ditemi un
attimo mai più
allora posto è tutto a posto che niente
perché pensavo di averlo fatto ancora un
po troppo no e quindi ho detto male
magari era un po troppo dovevo andare un
po più piano ma un altro 6 ragdoll lato
to malissimo per me ora questo ora
questo mi aveva avuto il salto programma
peccato perché stava raccogliendo troppo
solo lì a francica se la nazione di
portali loket righe certo voglia tra
codici laden se non fare il montain che
da un po che non la faccio che arrivò se
mi mettono sempre in prima fila e va
sempre bene
12 funaio in terza fila nascono mac sarà
dai dai dai dai
attenzione e grande show down hanno
cambiato il colore delle piattaforme
attenzione nuova sito nuova season
cambia ancora e piattaforme alcune hanno
le corone
ok ok vedo l'ora di vedere perché parte
parte più veloce comunque qual è il nome
la parte più veloce vero parte molto più
veloce
questo sembra è distinto il sole rotori
condizione europa
mauro ha sì sì sì sì lo so quali altri
quando è vero conti no non ho rega volta
si salta salta non saltano no no no no
sono state la piattaforma peccato che mi
ha spinto lui vai e ti secondi non sei
caduto o caduto sì perché mi è rimasto
nella vita aveva superato ma mi è
rimasto nella piattaforma che stava
accadendo che palle
in questo aggiornamento byrds bello del
calcio dauno la modalità preferite sono
tenuti a riva per adesso il gioco
peccato è rimasto lì
spiga ovviamente rai tornando alle
classe grazie brother grazie caro the
shadow ottima vede la preview 1 penso
che sia molto simile a quello che stanno
facendo
la play 5 che scende quello che si fanno
online
la lobby coda è bellissimo quello che
abbiamo visto la presentazione quello
che poi c'è in tutti gli sport bcc del
paracadutismo tutta l'area e tutti sono
prova a cambiare anima
raga mette un'altra skin se ho capito
bene che giocava un gioco così della
play uno bellissimo sarebbe di bici così
provano percorsi cittadini a può
sembrare noioso però è molto divertente
vi ricordo che per andare veloce devi
premere tante volte hicks infatti avevo
il pollice alf però niente né a partire
non ma non va via il gioco addirittura
si sono due ragazzi si sono due perché
avviato ma non c'è ok bravate buttarci
un controllo al calcio e chiudere magari
processi in background fans mattina è
partito che
ah boh non lo so ha aggiunto problemi
contro problema non so se gli conviene
schedulare l'ho ancora for guys
io adesso vedo ragazzi vediamo vediamo
perché mi dispiacerebbe comunque un bel
gioco a parte il fatto che non è bello
invece la prova dei più grossi problemi
però vorrei provare a far uscire un
altro paio di video poi ci mettiamo un
parto ma al 90 ma da soli non ho fatto
niente
ormai ha perso le speranze ai lati
insisti sentivo più non sto male sono
sempre per terra e non ho fatto tanto
non arrivò prima non arrivò prima
possibile arrivare prima rete che non
più se palle dai dragoni c visti questa
è pericolosa dico io te nella martello
di me on next o poi siamo gli unici
produttori che aggiungono paga invece di
rimuoverli esatto sono classificato di
la j
già ma in realtà non è che
come si dice in inglese non è mica bello
questi tempi va avere esplosivo reca con
una una via una vittoria una vittoria
vogliamo ma volete mettere un
maledettissimo hexagon ma anche giorgio
d'alia tanto va bene che avuto sfiga di
cacchio anche già basta che non sia col
monte basta che non sia col monte basta
che non sia quello ma tanto lo siamo già
in finale no esempio se qua si elimina
un botto di gente non si fa i fatti
propri motivo voglio fare cuscino nomi
disconnette al cielo da un'ora che
avrebbe fatto vedere i tempi una
posizione poi connection error
ecco adesso la prassi in prima posizione
davanti
vai vai vai brockman action al quale ha
toccato perché ora il gol gli altri 90
no per ora incollato la roma era
crollata quello non ha tolto non s'è
tolto bravo questo schifato libera la
società però non uno buono buono della
gara design clyde
pensa se fosse sul monte in forze in
file tutte corone per anche lì per una
buona perché se parti primo st
vantaggiato però tanto formano bene così
quindi vediamo se scaparro scritto il
martello
no perché perché mira colli survey io lo
skip del martello non lo posso fare
quegli atenei del mio parere stronzo
questo sentite guarda o no no rialzati
sì dai
la facciamo normale dai dai che la
facciamo normale fai tutto il giro è
bravo va bene dai facciamo la così
ok
ma poi l'hanno tolto hai visto che hanno
tolto i classificati
sì è vero non si sente milano tolti e
aspetto solo non per portare giulia tema
perché voglio arrivare ma nonna nonna
brutto di visto ti prego di mi disse no
frate no vorrei che ho rischiato
tantissimo territorio stimolato visto il
bordino migliorate ma quanto rischiato
se non c'è ma nicolò sotto prato eroso
sarei mesi mi sarei mi sarei mi sarei
buttato giugno dalla bocca di speranza e
disperazione
il senso di colpa allora mi ricorda il
pc ma lavora l'incontro di sumo e anche
questi temi vengono eliminati tutti e
due sono ma guarda ma fanno alla fine di
step prima nel coraggio cosa successo va
bene i regali e passato tutta la vita
davanti perché non avete idea di quanto
slittato ma ancora prima che la di mika
basse proprio lì dove c'erano all'inizio
di pendoli o slittato tantissimo ma gigi
però dai vediamo se c'e un job showdown
anche un polmone
tanto siamo in dodici ex in vabbè può in
quattro per squadra
4 no speriamo non l'avrebbe ecco questo
avrei evitato questo avrei evitato di
farla adesso per quanto nuova perché in
quattro e un suicidio è un sì allora
programma un'altra lotoro ok sulla cura
dio sulla prima d'ora non stato
sull'altra chi è che la presa scusa ti
prendi prendi prendi perché se la prendi
abbiamo presa minto perfetto mai mai mai
poi c'è uno dei nostri tutti i matia fa
gli affari tuoi io sto portando 9 d
occhio stati per un attimo in difesa per
favore se 67 va bene se no io però vai
vai ritieni tieni le passò butti giù e
se se questo sotto davvero ancora che
tanto non ci sta uscendo nessuno
primocanale sono periodo telepass sulle
bottiglie e bayern aveva anche arriva un
giallo per poi si è spostato dentro
occhio e tanto delle passa di qua non
fatelo perché è difficile portare uova
fuori non fatele a portar fuori per
favore ha portato tanti aspetti ha
portato fuori ma fatto non lo so è
saltato con l'uomo in mano e antonio dai
che c'è l'idea che c'è in programma la
maledizione uno solo buy back again
lasciamo stare a posto ok ma non ci sono
più uova
dobbiamo aggrappare come gli altri vabbè
manteniamo le nostre e dei nostri tanto
vediamo prima per questo adesso esce da
qua a sinistra e guardano nasce la
destra perfetto se ero io se nulla io
ero io avevamo perso 62 punti se ero io
ok raga il momento di tenere equa
prendi quello e quando blu ok non ce
l'ho fatta prima ma non dal club dal
fatto che mi sa che mi è caduto addosso
capito si vede che ci è andato parla
veramente non ho parole
ok giungeva buono buono
raga allora siamo in otto ma io allora
in otto ex a con lo farei dai ti prego
basta basta col monte veramente io farei
un bel extra con in 8 dai ammettilo
potete vedere nero
daje e daje barreto dai line one time è
fattibile non è io non è full monty
mandai applicato non siamo il novecento
quindi gigi non mi cambia niente se
aggiungiamo solo in 82 71 io sì perché
la gente c'è più probabilità di trovare
quello stupido che mi club ha capito sin
certo per quello madonna ma veramente ha
cambiato un po la velocità del giro un
casino
cioè il casinò è subito lotta realizza
parecchio
forse questi e vantaggiato uno che non
ci ha mai giocato perché non è non si
destabilizza occhio che secco accade è
questa qua ci conviene buttarci subito
appena che ma che non perdiamo non l'ha
già ecco no guarda non doveva accadere
solo la gialla e adesso conta ci fai che
accade questa tanto guarda la guarda ma
non aveva neanche niente niente ma è
incredibile ha messo lui non aveva
neanche l'avevo neanche dubbi perché dal
momento eravamo 23 se cazzola gialla non
accadere perché si chiedeva l'altro
avevamo tempo di buttarci non ho neanche
dubbi guarda credibile incredibile
neanche dubbio vero neanche uno vabbè
vabbè questa questa europa dovrebbero
cioè è pura casualità presto casualità
se ora che non puoi fare una cosa che in
finale è pura casualità secondo sulla
sulla finale
no le altre ci sta e randomico però va
bene dai
vabbè dai almeno nella forma del a mio
avviso roma poi se almeno garello quali
sono i capitali importanti nessuno ci
sono più bug
leo è crashato e non riesce a tal
analisi a caprese minchia sul computer
di praticamente
uno bello come raoul bova bova poco
felice dal testo giu penso sia vero figo
non puoi non vivo
mammamia vedi che questa mia capacità di
riconoscere gli artisti ma guarda che
sarebbe veramente giocata così
si son peccato che sia modificata solo
nel nella foto l'uomo cosa pist cosa pi
stato che il cavo delle cuffie o meno
degli altri cia risucchiati bocciati
tutti accigliati la put cioè ma ci
stiamo rendendo conto
non è una cosa normale e non è mica
bello questo allora morali anzi lo
volevo che lo accetterò più viola ma
città più di nato e quello che voglio
intendere i colleghi mi raccomando
sempre belle sode vieni le belle tre
operai o la fontina meno una vittoria
volevo arrivarci oggi dai molossi natura
girate la bellezza della sito della
prodezza che dir si voglia una vittoria
ma cosa che schifo fatto raga quartiere
intensi su mamma mia bellissima
bellissima vi giuro è una gran cosa qua
teoricamente non so se frate arrivi
primo non so perché qua e qua l'ultima
sommariva prima quello che state prima
perché quando bilanciarla e poi salire
ora invece ok il primo prima bella li
onesta questa partita della gima donna
ho fatto un record abbastanza importante
di velocità e l'attenzione
se come quasi non record del mondo
vivente ma era stavano lì è perché più
veloce di così farla suo nome è
difficile ho fatto veramente la velocità
massima che questa dovrebbe scendere
dovrebbe scendere
ecco ecco leo lasciami 6 insomma non è
il solo a riavviare il computer ma ha
messo a partiti gli anti cheat the steam
ma perché sei troppo forte e quindi
pensano le cose ci sono veramente cosa
dire una sfiga immonda ma pure mentre se
li abbiamo comprati che comparivano
tutte le cose
la foto deciso mary compariva cambiato
qui i flashback mentre 6 a cena con gli
amici tranquillissimi vuote vedi solo in
bianco e nero
la musica non questa
gioco a pagamento si ragazzi un po di
bug per un po di soldi per un pugno di
bug cambiamenti belli raga le mappe
nuove linee che sei culo le trovi ha
riportato una di il basket 2000 scheda
video we are my appena vide quella foto
si toglie che si traccia deciso io me ne
vado
maria io esco va via io esco ragazzi ce
la faccio più dista skin che ho comunque
devo devo averne sbloccarne un altro
devo stare un giorno di che adesso mi
capisco che secondo me potremmo
organizzarci per fare un giro perché
venga torino godo
però vengo per fare un giro poi passo
con i miei dopo ok ma per tutto il
pomeriggio sono tranquillo e libero
ricordi titoli concerto non avendoci a
sordo capitoli con ricordo qualche volta
però non non me la ricordo io se con
tante quanti ricorda vi ha detto questo
video vincete una corona che non a
stravincere e ci ricordiamo di darvela
perfetto pensiamo il blu ma se scheda
grafica il credo non ci credo è una
alucard grazie mille canali rai presente
a lucca comics quest'anno insieme tipo
con email
grazie per la donazione caro o cara
[Musica]
allora non lo so qual è il luca tornò
luca come se fino a ottobre era a quad è
halloween i ragazzi fino a ottobre 31
ottobre allora no perché insomma lo
avrebbero già comunicato c'è non è detto
ma 99 per cento non sono bravi abbiamo
già comunicato
purtroppo ragazzi come dico sempre in
tutte le leve lo ricordo la situazione
difficilmente gestibile per gli eventi
purtroppo c'è immaginate quanto possa
essere problematico per noi che facciamo
gli eventi non possiamo fare un po come
i cantanti che non possono cantare
proposto da fare gol certo a rinunciare
la stessa cosa perché tra gli
assembramenti la cosa nome non è tanto
per non è non è tanto per la cosa non è
tanto per l'assembramento perché magari
organizzando sia anche con il
distanziamento si può fare sempre meglio
evitare l'evitabile però magari non è
tanto quello ma è proprio il momento di
incontro con noi che non si può fare
perché capisci tu te che te frega di non
incontrare quello di fianco che c'è in
fila fa niente della distanza però con
me quindi è proprio quello il discorso
non ce lo fanno fare giustamente quindi
finché non abbiamo news
non c'è quando avrò news lady o ecco
quindi no ragazzi purtroppo purtroppo
non si può far purtroppo non conosci
filippo che anche mentre profitti gioca
chiama dai incerto però conosco cosa sì
sì te lo giuro che punti restando lo
riconosco perché a me ma è un è un
creator a ok a luglio e no aspetta
cavolo ma tu non hai mai conosciuto
no era già pro football guys
il ragazzo che faceva i fido
sull'università
hai visto quello che fai minuti le
volontà universitarie le prendi in giro
milioni camente non ho mai visto è un
mio caro amico si salutavano di profeti
saluta lorenzo favi j
non mi sta cambiando la visuale no
ragazzi si è rotto joystick a veti che
pure a tema d'assaro ma non vogliono dai
per favore ti prego ti prego tipi di
pubblico
ok mamma mia l'orario è servito per ora
vediamo adesso la gente quanto cime per
capire che deve nazione il re tempo e
tranquillo però tanto sono ancora tutti
e ciccia tikwa
guarda che fa i salti in avanti molto
più di quello che sembra dettata da roma
non ci posso salire quasi però e tu col
joystick spento eric sei più avanti ma
mi sei mancato ma è vero fine timing
devo tanto non riuscivo a fare questa
cosa state facendo tutti quindi mi porto
questo è la faccio quarda direttamente
nel libro semi spostate razzo ma devo
saltare col tuffo che aveva parola basta
poco gioco non ce la faccio minime di
oggi o una cosa che gli altri non hanno
ovvero mi buttano giù e io non posso
votare giulia ti ho perso storico al
traguardo invece non posso vincere
possiamo vita perché gli attimi buttano
giù io non posso buttarlo quindi come la
spiegamelo io non posso vincere
che cazzo sposti idiota
io veramente non si arrampicano
s'arrampica nicchia che odio raga che
odio e qui siamo le mappe che mesetto fa
poco un cazzotto però è bella cina non
posso fare io non possono farla crollare
gli altri quindi calcio del gioco ha
fatto allora siamo tutti e due zio cosa
ti devo dire niente per attaccanti che
fanno le mie ripetute si pagano di far
bollare ok grazie meno male perché non
potevo fare nient'altro che forse non
c'è mai ma vedrai che il culo xvi ma ma
se non me lo dicevi omero bullish allo
yoga pure ho dovuto fare il giro dove
c'era gente che non si stava
arrampicando perché siamo a rovigo
boillat lì ho perso perché io a me
buttano giù io non ci posso fare niente
se mi toccano caso io sta cosa non l'ha
capito io però già patiscono mese io
mando st live ma a quali la miglia toni
che mi guardano come dire ma com'è
possibile perché non è possibile ragazzi
ve lo giuro ma perché si legge allora
concentrati concentrati chi io da solo
si giocherà solo qua dai una canzone dei
sì li si guarda che sono propri di più
per i rammstein però non li si che si
hanno fatto nuba brano un brano dopo
brano hanno chiamato la j
la chitarra elettrica vai vai vai
esattamente dovevano dare il mio bravo
si può far male
ormai non ci arrivò mai stato e non so
niente qualificato
eh sì perché l'ho visto che si sta
alzando il punto per un mondo ad un
giallo
questo gioco me la cavo paura di farlo
prendere il giallo dove prendere il
giallo però non tifo più stare su quel
riguarda se stai è però varando c'è un
altro giallo la roma ce li guardi con la
vita nessuno era visto impostare questo
però ce la puoi fare
si siano piano piano bravi bravi
ecco qua di nuovo va bene se stai fermo
e capace di non andare in paranoia
perché tanto è pieno e pieno c'è anche
se stai fermo in un punto ti spara in
faccia eccolo nervo ha letto e credibile
dillo che lei mandato giù 20 io che
nella mandavo fila di una scelta di vita
poco faccia per farsi siena faccia piero
va bene bene bene ok ma sei stupido ma
sposta vera e c'è gente che non era
presente anche uno stati la fama si ma
questo comunque io data inizio live non
ancora esposta ad uno certo non a lei lo
zugo quanto pollo ti pago seguito pac e
farina e ci sembra veramente siamo
sempre quello quando facciamo le tv
elettronico
la cosa più stupida che questo me nella
mia vita cioè il pollo fare i fari
tesissimo la gallina le reti a 2 e va
pure il culo riuscito a cadere tra
l'altro la preside e due le mancano due
ragazzino quello a coso giallo lì era da
due ore la poteva prendere era da solo e
la mancato miserable abilmente per
questo è uno gelato vince chi sa perché
adesso uno e poi l'altro fa peccato ma
dai ma non è ma lo vedi la piatta
pallone ma chi la tira più facile adesso
cade non è caduto non se lo meritava mai
ci ha fatto veramente stalevo la mamma
mio pensiero proprio è la meta le fa
questa mano quasi bye bye bye bye 40 per
cento
papà papà
ecco qua ok quanti siamo
otto sono visto ma dai dai dai dai dai
dai dai che possono non correte per
l'amore del signore vi prego non correte
per buzz vizio completo questo ma adesso
perché vedrà schindel correte hai
cambiato la skin e del mese messo al
corrente che avrete pure ragazzi mi
sembra thriller piatto sia camera si la
tesi cambiata perché stavolta stick a
quella la cosa bella è che saltano no
corri bertolo e pura corri dal bullo che
proprio non ho parole
ma tutti qua anche con la cosa con i ma
stai fermo ma perché corrono per
eliminarti il terreno ma si eliminano da
soli non de vico perché chi elimina le
devi correre per elimina il terreno se
sei tu e un altro e un altro ancora non
se siamo tutti se siamo tutti cosa corri
a fare 66 un babbo perché prima che
perde 626 proprio è proprio stupida come
da altri hanno comunque bruttissima cosa
dei colori che sono uguali tra
piattaforme perché certe capisce niente
si capisce nulla ma mi sa che hai fatto
apposta che cacchio sei tolto il casco
guarda guarda guarda guarda la gente un
neurone solo che balla la macarena
non c'è questo ci arrivo è arrivato a
toccare anche tu pirla ecco pure più
sotto 6 cascavel i veri guarda quanto è
servito corner pista ma togliendo in
mezzo e come al solito viola in mezzo
non c'è già più stanno correndo che lo
devo capire dove buttarmi sai niente ci
mangiamo tutti i morti genocidio di
folgaria ma sai perché guarda cosa ho
fatto ti prego guardare il lancio perché
mi sono visto che tutti eravamo allo
stremo allora ho detto se prendo un
tempo in più ce la faccio
mamma però del tu sei caduto molto prima
di me assurdo trasmettergli poi mi sono
buttati in avanti e mai ho fatto la tua
stessa roba cosa è comunque gigi gigi
sono contento che ho assurdo perché come
ho dato una rapida occhiata agli altri
visto che stavano tutti per cadere ho
detto oh meno male però male comunque
comunque a prescindere dalla vittoria
ragazzi mamma mia ma che fatica
e ormai parlano di materiali la parata
per fare una vita tre ore e tre ore di
gioco una vittoria tre o ci sono le
volte che giochiamo un ora ne facciamo
tre e adesso tre ore una vittoria dai ma
cos'è incredibile poi ho detto stiamo
tutti i gorghi drid asciugamanini certi
infognati pesante guarda che informò
onde incorrere france info montini next
a concorrere funziona se hai una per ti
ricordi come l'ho fatto fuori
dall'ultima live con la che stava da
solo per li avete visti correre perché
gli taglia la strada ma se siamo in 200
se corri sei un de pensante perché
imparo loda pensate bene tenere un tg
ragazze per la di niente maraga futuro
buono dai almeno arrivato in finale
federico mai filangieri fissa salame
piccante salame piccante pista stessa
bruciato anche tu raga io lo conosco da
sette anni i rami dediti a cornice che
soddisfazione sono contento di annate
per per il miglior del cus urbino lungo
il telefono bel haj let's colour haga
questa mappa nuova sono concediamo raga
però a mamma mia che fatica cioè io
veramente non dopo il primo tentativo a
rete da gente si sta perché mi vien da
dire che stanno giocando per i forti ma
se vi giuro che correre e la tattica
sbagliata
quindi non mi sento di dire che non
forti specie mente che rompevano le
scatole buono pubblico quest'anno
mascherata è tutto visto però davanti
che adesso no adesso perdo una cacata
invece no mammamia record mondiale siamo
primi secondi
pazzesco sinistra baffa dietro ma serata
però citare che l'amalgama mi ha subito
lo sbaglio tutto lo aspettavo
mikael allora ci racconti più di due
feroci racconti più nulla di te giocando
a rocket era una cosa bellissima è
perché ho finito di raccontare storie
finite le storie dei motivi 25 anni non
200 se volete inventor no no no finito
nelle parti di scherzi vita no ti
ringrazio per come pensato però devo
trovare robe perché ogni tanto riescono
fuori di qua una volta è successa una
roba racconto capito non mi vengono in
mente sul mio perché tante cose non sono
certo però comunque le cose main l'ho
detto che se va bene tutto farebbe
veramente ridere
siete stati classificati e ceo te a
questa fosse brava a st
si va dunque è stata rotta era il cavo
raga che non funzionava bene prima non
so perché ma prima venisse tolto a caso
a meghni che a me ma sto pappagalli am
see our di gente stagione vedo nessuno
dritto poi si apre guardiamo cascate un
altro solo dritto guarda musivi aprì la
strada 20 anni va bene anche lì seria e
pappagalli e poi ma la bambola nel fiume
cento no non la sai no questa roba
scusami la bambola film horror
allora io avevo raccontato a noa
spettacolo il regalo che avevi fatto
ok ok adesso sì allora o quadrate
frammentazione degli ordinato di
frammentazione
ma sai tu le sai è bella questa allora
io ho regalato a la faccio veramente le
stretta che sono qua due ore ho regalato
a marco marino nel turno l'hanno scopo
sé un ricordo
no così l'anno scorso ok a giugno erano
suonate adesso comprendo gli ho regalato
una bambola
con una bambola è un paese rizzata
pressurizzata gone in che senso
in un continuo è quel tipo di bambini ma
non è quella che si gonfia ma ok e
quell'altra che è proprio fatta da
moronti fatta proprio da cristo è
infatti perché fatto il video che ho
fatto troppo di prevedere che insomma
lui apprezzarlo venire io ora ha
incollato per te sono perche ci sono
solo nichi cioè io potessero dura terra
ha raccontato mi era incollato 135 va
bene è uscita stadio regalato stampa
abbiamo fatto di non c'è mia fattoria
abbiamo fatto ho fatto il video non ho
neanche ripresa per quanto non ci sia
niente di strano se le menti vestiti
però comunque va bene la zona poco un
contenuto
regalatevi fr le cerniere passano in due
mesi e io pensavo si fosse stancato
della suddetta bambola vabbè comunque
insomma io ero a e roero ero in america
era new yorker guarda a tipo una
settimana settimane era new york
ero nel presente mi sveglio e roero in
camera c'è la mia ex ragazza ai tempi
ero era lì stava dormendo mi sveglio la
mattina perché non ho ancora vinto col
jet lag mi sveglio e siccome lei stava
gradualmente avviamento linee scrollo il
telefono ascolterebbero su facebook e
vedo mi appaiono le news di di milano
today che una pagina di milano invece di
juncker o manto di neve
e leggo leggo tragedia vabbè una roma
esagerata tipo spavento nomi come si
cresce da jasper una roba esagerata è
cosa praticamente avevano mobilitato la
polizia
la squadra mobile lalli pompieri e
l'ambulanza perché avevano rinvenuto un
corpo in un fiume
9 io ho detto mamma mia che è successo
un disastro aprle la notizia dice il
falso allarme perché in realtà non era
un corpo era una bambola in silicone che
qualche pirla l'ha buttata via in un in
un fiume per a cui io penso e dico mamma
mi ha chiesto pirla poi la guardo e dico
ma cacchio ma si assomiglia proprio
leggo dove leggo dove si doveva entrato
stanno peggio in vicinissimo dove abita
marco detto no è allarmatissimo
allarmatissimo chiamo marco allarmato ma
allarmato proprio in una maniera il tuo
talento 9 armato niente non ci credo
siro me l'hai presa veramente non me
l'hai driver misero hai preso veramente
cresciamo facciamo ancora un paio
allarmato allarmato chiamo marco per lui
della serie che comunque va beh non è
che dava e cioè non hai fatto niente
però ha inquinato non si inquina e due
ai mobilitato con pieni polizia squadra
mobile
ambulante suv i superano andati via
detto il preside pericolo perché uno
l'avrà visto era chiamato ha chiamato
quindi devo sapendo che condanno cioè
nel senso anche se non è successo niente
alla fine però che concordando quindi io
mi sono chiesto allarmato chiamo marco
non risponde tra l'altro era e la
mattina da me new york è un tipo le 7 e
le 8 ma in a in italia c'erano erano
faiotto p6 che orami è uscito in italia
alle 2
auguro a me uscito in italia erano le
due e marco ancora una c'è mi ero
sbagliato prima io che lui né col prima
io col jetlag che lui mi hanno svegliato
prima io new york che sei all indietro
che lui in italia della pazzia
allora ho chiamato daniele che l'amico
privato in titanio
occhio che marco potrebbe aver fatto una
cazzata ma va va va va va
e da lì fanno no tranquillo prove sta
qua la bam
pensavo fosse la sua perché ho detto ma
qua va cova nei casinò tacco a marco è
finito niente ha detto poco serve però
attenzione il 20 è anche uscito dal
gruppo thule e se ci sono poteri mito
niente quindi allarmato ragazzi ora che
non lo sapevo vabbè c'è una storia dvd
che racconta per bene solo stretta
perché ci sono poi i dettagli e io ho
detto mamma mia quanto è finito è finito
non è che tale non hai fatto niente però
guarda adesso che mi è venuto in mente
la vita potrebbe essere procurato
allarme ti procurato allarme
no no quello sicura fino rischi morello
penale quello è a culo infatti marco ha
detto poi finisce nei casini perché lo
da perché parco non è proprio la persona
più pulita del mondo no quindi ho detto
c'è pulita a livello di spirito
quindi ho detto si vede affatto una
cagata quindi io non lo avverto della
serie o poi occhio che magari il video
era pure online quello qui allegata
certo
però va beh insomma nera suoi non era
lui abbiamo visto allarmato per niente
pensa però quel pirla che ha lanciato
stampa amore va bene niente abbiamo
sempre c'è il sub che si è dovuto
buttare nel fiume di mattina magari
celano un freddo incredibile ha visto
che nella banda eletto va bene io da new
york mi sono accorto di sta roba di
connection un articoletto amore per la
propria città
ciao saggio marchigiane e son contenta
vecchia masto mio amico e non so come ti
sei salvato libro non avevano provato lo
giuro ma tu no ma ok tu hai visto cosa
ho fatto io no
molto bene molto pesante all'interno
poco dietro vita cosa è successo niente
tipo non so che cosa mi ha lanciato in
aria
anzi quella roba lì sulla piattaforma
viola mi ha lanciato in aria però non
uno sconfinato e quindi mi ha tenuto
dentro arrivando davanti un grande
bomber per altre ricette seguitemi video
di roche league
[Musica]
beh
madonna lega ma un tempo ma ce l'hai
mezzo tempismo poverino che sapete
colori che si mamma mia ma tutti vista
per tutti la sveglia sta andando tecnico
da è vero ma dai che tutte le previste
se la faceva il contrario era perfetto
ma fino adesso dieta per passare dritta
non prenderne una velocità roma a
prenderle furti li ha presi lui per il
boss è questa non so se l'ultima ragazzi
credo di sì perché comunque siamo troppo
sotto orario ragazzi peccato che
arrivato coprirà un'area oggi no no no
no quello sì sto dicendo che fare un po
di tanto non facciamoci in cuore non ci
ragazzi scusate ma avevo un lavoro
importante sono new thing set ma non si
era fatto oggi non ancora no c'e bisogno
di una rock è i los angeels ato io non
so se fame jeans è dipende io fuggo
allora se mgx sono subito non mi faccio
chissà perché me la cavo sia non esserci
in stato sia viaggi in sale però io più
a jeans al massimo fino al massimo che
posso nata la canzone non è che voglio
al massimo de posso cantare canzoni mai
una season splendida alta parliamo
romano quanto le ormai è credibile
oddio ma questo qua era era un 5 non
avevo visto sì certo dai quanto è quanto
è potente questo wifi quanti gigahertz è
che cos'è la scontri che forse è che
costa e lasko teca è lasko teca ai tuoi
compagni ti possono jinx aree non mi
ricordo milione di tutti non jing sati
c'è di qing salti sicuramente una vasta
all'art
non vedo la gente eccolo qua la perfetta
il mio lo fate voi dai sì che mai
io adesso ce l'ho mi manca di loro
acceleriamo sulla carta 92 apposta oggi
altre li e li guardo dove sono io no ma
era sotto la piattaforma quando vero io
che spiega che sfiga da ancora una
parola
vamos vamos 7 a 2
vito una cosa di corone io tra l'altro è
tutto questo genere che cos'è lasko teca
era para papapapapapapapapapappappa pa
pa pa pa pa pa pa scusatemi asia la
seconda season e lo racconterà di come
la seconda season e conciso non era sì
ma ci siano ragazzi che vi raccontavamo
sensi ci vediamo subito della terza
season è bancato un calzino del libero
che mi sto portando cibo aver pagato
quel guerra
oggi mi hai fatto venire voglia di una
poche di inviato la foto pochi sembrano
la bocchetti ok family friendly
sì perché poteva perché te l'ho detto
non è messo meglio da porre è se
immediato la foto no e quindi dovrò
andare ieri a mangiare il sushi con mio
cugino ma non ce l'ho fatta perché ho
finito di lavorare troppo tardi
mannaggia dicono al mio lavoro e quindi
come stato a far più di voi e le sue
belle toglierà sicuramente questa
modalità adesso vediamo quante volte
mila donne sull'elica ragazzi
e successo a te non ti ha fatto entra no
no funziona problemi è libero vi porto
il sugo di mia mamma la torino frate noi
ce lo abbiamo mangiato di mamma mia che
esca anche dal petrolio è fantastico
oggi basso e niente
ci provo ragazzi che da una vita che non
prova il sinistro perché a sinistra
perché se no non so chi allora
volevo provare ad ora che sono sono
stupido sono stupido che devo fare
l'alta definizione del quadro dopo primo
addio vai si no
da ma in realtà perché sto facendo un
cretino questa settimana ragazzi dipende
da quanto va bene solo a quello viene
dai dati di acea ti piace l'uguale di
aiace
ero morto ok vamos voglio salutare ogni
atto che vi sta seguendo un bacio caro
saluta omi bella brava ti seguo da
quando imita via strategico per dato a
questo tagliato fuori una perla questa
era la perla vera si partecipa of duty è
certo che si concedono aiuti come duty
che variano misto tra toscana americano
meli mano tirato fuori gli strategico e
incredibile ritorno indietro di mille
anime la prima perché la prole ragazzi
nel passato è passato e pepe era più pa
pa pa pa pa pa pa
magari c'è una fame aimee mann ieri al
tavolo abbiamo due fra
io ho un muro lo posso fare è consentito
a riposo primario all opposto
ecco la casa eccola qui che la mia
scheda video è pronta a lottare
questa che pensa che noi pensa che noi
abbiamo inizia quasi per il 5 avevo
iniziato a fare video era quello è
quello che tu avevi visto questo video
sono giovanni ha visto già nei grigioni
rogo era era legale euro ad esempio
mamma mia che i tempi dai ragazzi siamo
la roma di siena va infatti dai frate
però sempre supportato anche quando mi
hai addebitato 50 euro nella stanza
d'albergo cosa ricordo sicuro che sei
stato tu
noi ricorda tanto la propagati viola
paese ci siamo è a un evento e poi certo
punto la mattina mi son ritrovato tipo
l'abitazione mia stanza un sacco di roba
però mi immagino che possa stupire
sicuro è stato lui poi va bene non li ho
pagati comunque io perché non evento
dove c era era spesato d'albergo però
pensa che riina come situazione si si no
giuro non sto scherzando
ammettilo visitato ma lo sai che ci sono
o no no guarda la chat mentre il gioco
della figlia ma tu l'hai ci sai che non
ho capito al comando con una foto sul
gruppo possa invece adesso lo guardo
troppo penare sco aspettatevi prego
questa ragione
questa è la foto questa è la foto di
euro cospetto si sono così bella stava
fa bello sto caricamento e quindi piace
lefort caccia marca è si vede che non ha
trovato giocatori dai si dava la proprio
fa giocare male no e mi odiano i tavoli
azzurro è caduto veramente male basta f4
questi se tutto va bene così davvero
niente va bene così tutto niente tutto
no ma c'è quello azzurro e aveva degli
evidentissimi problemi deambulatori
poveraccio
p giulio solo così solo fa solo quella
schermata è agghiacciante quello che
dicono mi accende quello che dicono
ok c'è uno che si chiama incerto e
lorenzo casadio e la cosa ti fa fare più
ridere regalare un si legge dai ragazzi
con la nuova almeno almeno sul finale
abbiamo vinto una volta in tre ore è
imbarazzante presenza ma il bello è che
io esco e vesco poter leggere una mappa
nuovo ai timpano aspetti in timbrica
pallone ti conosco stefano che siamo
partiti vicino detto nuovo city allora
ci dobbiamo fissare su quelli dorati e
fra io vorrei conquistare ma che sono si
sposti che stan tenta di spostare kong
però sta aspettando
siccome però io gialli non ci cascano in
mezzo due invece sono passato non so
neanche io come ma sul passato altro qua
gigi reggono d'oro
follina lo prende nessuno no mi spiace
per lei che ha beccato carica ma ce l'ha
fatta intravisto nove ragazzi non fate
ridere ma fate ridere ma faccio ridere
non ci sono entrato neanche io e quindi
dovrò per forza giustificarmi
abbiamo dieci possiamo stare insieme no
fra è successo ci possiamo integrare la
festa quest'urlo valeva più dell'hard
della del successo del cielo era tutto
quello che volevo dap è stata questa
giocata al furlo no è la storta peccato
come dai extra e non ci si può entrato
peccato nel caso la storia 22 da un
sacco di qualità il caso erano meno
qualificato bravo
niente devo devo smetterla di andare
dove vanno gli altri perché io dovunque
vado prendermi prendono cerchi quindi
non posso fare nulla strana sta partita
non sto facendo niente ma totalmente
niente 01 da una coppa nell'angolo di
dove sono io non vedo niente stoffa
cesaro preso qualificato posso
assolutamente fare niente perché
qualsiasi cosa facciano un bel con
cerchi o forse questo prova a vedere se
detto questo ho preso un certo i ragazzi
forse c'è ancora speranza
poi a dirlo e sai che dispetto non sta
facendo niente
il latino uno per ogni e tumorali e too
much arriverà qualcun altro prima
purtroppo no non è tuo e tutto mancano
quanti lavorati ma quella cosa sanno gli
altri 102 gente a 1 un sacco di gente a
1.30 c'è gente in base a parigi tv
benvenuto in giacomo brother grazie
mille
ho preso il cerchio fratelli adesso mi
conviene stare fermo che scendono però
adesso che non ha tre scendono in testa
lo stai quattro su sei bravo ma parola
da tutti e due secondo me no
tra l'altro non rompere il cazzo pure
quello dorato diceva cosa ma cosa ma il
gioco fatto con i piedi un gioco fatto
con i piedi
io veramente o no non me ne vado perché
sai noi vediamo in stallo scivolo
disinstallo disinstalla voi ragazzi si
installano da mano si sta alla vera
mente quello che vado a doppia milano
roma si misura a 6 punti mi doveva
classificate anche per la modalità dopo
quel io veramente no io guarda non posso
fare stabilità lo dico subito
ice nota la macchina sia sta roba
cioè son contento perché almeno
giochiamo le nuove modalità però questa
qua non era un po così
una cosa è un po così a che loro ne
lasko teca è che cos'è lasko teca è co
dai
ma a milano da manuale o si muove e vive
lo finisco st partire master hanno
mascherato ma non ho certo quello che
comincio a pensare che il mio crush
dipende dai giochi dopo quando si decide
i giochi dopo io credo che questo non ce
l'ho fatta
adesso ormai molto più faceva
arrampicarsi di cana guarda puoi vedere
guarda me l'ha preso me l'ha preso me
l'ha preso ma spostata e sta piattaforma
decelebrati spostate st piattaforma
decerebrati sì mi sono mangiato una r va
là che non ci si arriva se non si riesca
saremo perché musica ciascun livello se
niente niente niente è impossibile è
impossibile provare a salire minima cosa
mi gravi ma veramente ciò ha raddoppiato
da gara che non ci si arriva più non ci
serviva più raga da qua avvicinata e sta
piattaforma di dominare tracciato anche
a mano vabbè tanto dovevo andare non ti
vedo heather ma indietro non ce la
faccio facciamo lo facciamo facciamo
prova ci prova acceleratore però la
pancia piena e non hanno niente e bevo
ad amarlo guardata in ballo live e se lo
fanno quasi una dai cuori seduti o no se
l'avessi passo su prima ci avresti fatta
io la rima vabbè niente niente tg ma mi
sa che non l'ho fatto perché prima ci ho
provato un sacco di volte e non mi è
venuto detto vabbè tonica grazie toni se
non sbaglio e lijun abbonato grazie però
per il rinnovo di chi ma che skin
bellissima e ha più o meno sisters ne
parlerei un paio di minuti insegnante di
questa cosa però comunque ben climb no
hexagon la sua ne vediamo come va
proviamoci
e poi ti faccio il tifo per te
proviamoci dai one e vamonos con
l'ultima partita di oggi ragazzi
speriamo in un gioco pulito
eccolo qua gioco viene esattamente dove
sono io bravo con ricordi mi raccomando
mi raccomando che mica finisce la
piattaforma bravo bravo complimenti
bravo con gli ancora è bravo complimenti
così bravissimo vedi che sei sveglio
sempre detto che questo ragazzo è un
futuro nel gaming
complimenti al rango da meraviglioso
ride all
meno male che paritetico no ma lega blue
screen per leo a blue screen proprio al
jazeera
secondo me questo aggiornamento di for
guys mi ha fatto piacere bella season 2t
fatalmente olio bella la season 2
comunque ti fa talmente rage aree che
gli occhi distrugge il computer va bene
io sono cascato per questa mostra
giocando effettivamente ma io però
quello ultima correre quindi magari con
di colpo subito tanto lui perderà quindi
è questo che mi mi consola complimenti
che ho ricordi mi hai finito le
piattaforme micale a finite bravo
complimenti
ora questo che mi guarda e quando
tornano tutti 11 aperti se tutti tutti
ormai ex non è ingiocabile ragusa cavina
e corriamo corriamo tutti perdo come voi
ragazze vincerà l'unico pirla che avrà
un culo quadro che riuscirà a rimanere
in piedi dai corriamo tutti dai corriamo
tutti quanti l'isola sei piattaforme e
ctv assalterà corrono
vincerà l'unico pirla che si ritroverà
con un po diventa per me ne vogliate
perdere è perdete maledetti schifosi in
insulsi a questo gioco perché no vabbè
tk bella avevamo già vinta veniva niente
però corriamo da così corriamo tanto non
importa giocarla bene gigi gigi ragazze
ci sediamo che siamo tutti messi con una
fame finale
vi ringrazio per ha visto dai ragazzi
purtroppo non è l'inizio di season che
mi aspettavo però cosa vi posso dire
magari migliora magari migliora magari
si svegliano domani dicono nava
scherzava c'avevamo 65.000 mappe sa che
altro è quello più che altro è quello
perché le mappe nuove non sono brutte
però più ma sono però più ma non so xxiv
regata e vogliamo più mappe nuove 6 ori
spero che vi sia piaciuto vi ringrazio
aver visto nel video fino al dissestati
ma qua con noi se gli si arrivati fino
qua perché non so parlare è la fame di
rab la banca e la fama e la fama però i
ragazzi ci vediamo là funzionale
ringrazia di ringrazio leo cacia al blue
screen avrà cominciato a buttare
un bacino ci vediamo oggi è oggi è
giovedì giovedì domenica domenica
mattina la gara partirà come sempre io
domenica mattina sono col non lo so però
al 99 per cento sarò col telefono ok
però ci però non c'era che non ci sono
sono ok per le baby scaricati cose come
si dice pero stars in terrazzi di siena
ce l'ho già quello va bene a bacino raga
dyer
ciao regali da ragatzu all enit
ciao ci vediamo domani